this is jacqueline podcast number 349
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
powerful enemies
must be out fought and out produced
it is not enough to just turn out a few
more planes a few more tanks a few more
guns a few more ships that can be turned
out by our enemies
we must out produce them
overwhelmingly
so that there can be no question of our
ability to provide a crushing
superiority of equipment in any theater
of the world war
and that right there is what
president roosevelt
told congress
and america less than a month after the
attack on pearl harbor
and what he talked about doing
we did
america provided almost 70
[Music]
of the military equipment
for the allies in world war ii
297 000 aircraft 193 000 artillery guns
86 000 tanks 2 million trucks
2.6 million
submachine guns almost 12 million rifles
the u.s navy
grew from 700 ships
to almost 7 000
and that included 23 battleships and 151
aircraft carriers
and that
that
crushing superiority of production
and the brave men who brought those
weapons to bear against the enemy
overwhelmed
the nazis and the imperial japanese army
and america's ability to create and
produce
to design and manufacture this has
always been
one of our strongest assets as a nation
our working class the men and women of
this country that actually do these
things
that actually make these things happen
but that asset
and that capability
it faded
it faded and
manufacturing went overseas
we shut down a lot of our mills we shut
down a lot of our factories we abandoned
our communities we abandoned our
workforce
[Music]
we abandoned the american worker
and our rivals
around the world
they smiled
and they eased that transition for us
they helped us down that path they
offered cheap labor
basically slave labor they didn't care
about worker safety didn't care about
the environmental impact of what they
were doing but they were able to
they were able to win on price
but we paid the price
and we began to lose
that
incredibly valuable asset in our country
our ability to make things our ability
to build things our ability to create
and manufacture
and with the loss of that skill
with the loss of that asset
our
strength in the world began to diminish
began to fade
but
there's a new fire burning now
and there's a
a slow burning revolution occurring
there are companies
in america that have had enough of that
that are capturing the skills from the
past that are teaching the right people
that are
restoring the machines and resurrecting
the factories
there are people and companies that are
rebuilding america
into the strong
powerful
and benevolent nation it once was
and i am honored to be part
of some of those companies
with my business partner pete roberts
and we have
[Music]
we've invested everything we've got
into origin usa and into jocko fuel
and we are doing our best
in this
new war
an economic war yes it's an economic war
it's also a war of ideas
and it's a war of ideology
when you look at who we're up against
it's a war of skill
it's a war
of production it's a war of efficiency
and it's a war of grit
it's a war between state control
and self-determination
a war between subjugation and liberty
between slavery
and freedom
that's what's at stake
and that's not just rhetoric
that's what's going on
and it's great to have pete
back here with us tonight to talk about
the war that we're fighting right now on
all fronts
as we try to help rebuild
america
pete what's happening man badass man
powerful thanks for having me back on uh
pete roberts if you don't know who he is
podcast 93 podcast 141 podcast 194
podcast 297. that's we joined forces in
2017.
we recorded a podcast every year up here
at the origin main immersion jiu jitsu
camp
which we
there's a little gap in 2020 we got shut
down we weren't allowed to do jiu-jitsu
or allowed to do jiu-jitsu uh
at least not
in public yeah yeah we kept training i'm
sure you kept trying to
uh
so
this has turned out to be an annual
thing that we're doing and it's a good
opportunity for us to let people know
what's going on
share people some of the experiences
that we've had and some of the lessons
that we've learned because we're
learning we're learning a lot of lessons
along the way and giving everyone an
update as to what's happening so that
they can see sort of the big picture of
what's going on so
essentially we're talking about two
companies
and
really these two companies
i would say it's safe to say that they
started
as sort of as siamese twins right like
they were connected
and
you know they had a lot they shared a
lot of blood maybe yeah maybe shared you
know like they have three lungs total
one of the lungs was shared
you have two of those yeah
it's like so there's there's these
shared things going on one of the jocko
fuel obviously it's our it's our
supplement nutrition brand and the other
one's origin usa which is our hard goods
clothing
uh accessories
brand we got fitness products in there
too as well so a bunch of stuff but we
got these two companies so let's talk
about where we at where we're at uh with
these what's going on some of the
lessons we learned some of the tuition
payments that we've made
you know
you have your mba
i don't have [__] i'm a college dropout
okay so you don't have your mba i don't
have my mba echo do you have your mba no
nba but you know what we've learned some
business lessons and they can't teach
you and they've cost way more than an
mba
yes
uh so here we go let's let's start off
talking a little bit about jackal fuel
now what's interesting about this is
last last time we were together or i
guess during this time frame i guess we
didn't we didn't do it um
we were
getting to a point where we
as we had predicted
we were starting to need money
so we're starting to need money this is
a cash intensive business
making food products making supplements
being in retail
having to order
millions and sometimes tens of millions
of dollars worth of product
and having to pay for that
and then having to
to hold on and hold your breath and
pinch pennies
until maybe
90 120 180 days that money starts to
come back in we got we did a lot of
breath holding
in this ramp up and that's kind of phase
we were in last year around this time we
were in that
you know every quarter every month
really would be a breath hold waiting
for
you know payment to come in
is not a great feeling yeah and behind
the scenes you know last year during
camp when we were sitting around in
private talking about that cash to cash
cycle and
how we're starting to
burn cash or or feed the monster the
monster eats cash i mean knowing our
goals for you know mass distribution and
to try to get the things we're making in
the hands of humanity i mean america for
sure that it was gonna it was gonna be
expensive growth and
you know definitely
as committing to larger and larger
orders
should there some something that would
go wrong knowing that you then have to
dump
let's say screw-ups which has a massive
impact on cash flow also we didn't have
too many of those had a couple but um
yeah man the monster uh the monster
finally get fed
uh
got fed luckily with you know the
investment we took on with that great
investor but
burning burning that cash for so long
as long as we could
you know and knowing that the right
thing to do was to bring on a partner
that could help us blow this thing up
uh it was definitely challenging knowing
how we work together and how we make
decisions and how we communicate
and sticking somebody else in the mix
that we don't know and
trying to trust that process that
they're going to plug in easily
i think that for me was the most
difficult thing not even the other stuff
you know not having to dump flavor
systems or
you know over wrap cans because there's
a can shortage you know or like try to
try to pivot on you know uh where we're
buying our ingredients from it was
really
it was really trying to plug somebody
else into the equation it could have
gone terribly bad
if it wasn't done right so
obviously
you know we had some some decent offers
from the different private equity firms
and whatnot but
i honestly didn't think we were going to
find any at one point
i was kind of like damn this just isn't
going to happen and we're going to have
to
either shrink and rethink
you know or i i didn't i actually didn't
know yeah well we had i mean i remember
talking about plan a b c d yeah
uh and and that's what we had to do um
that
the the fact that you and i uh sometime
well often times we're making decisions
in i mean
multi-million dollar decisions in three
texts or seven text messages
and it's always been like that that is
definitely a scary thing to mess up
because and look i i have the benefit of
working with so many different companies
at echelon front that i see how hard it
is for companies to make decisions
sometimes when you have just a little
bit
different agendas going on and the
eagles pop up and all of a sudden simple
decisions that should take 15 minutes
they end up taking 15 weeks and i'm not
kidding like literally
simple decisions that you can see the
obvious answer for can take months
instead of minutes
and
we we were we were operating in the
minutes time frame and the the other
thing that was kind of cool
was because we were you know living
paycheck to paycheck for so long man we
were lean super late super lean ins you
know it was there was just no fat we
were like a fighter that had cut weight
and just barely made it right and we
were doing that you know it was like
wrestling season every wednesday and
every saturday we were making weight you
know we were trying to see if we could
shed a little bit we were sitting in the
sauna trying to squeeze out a little
another extra you know eight ounces
and
but it but but what i liked about that
is it made us good right it made us good
you know you asked someone that that
wrestled hey you tell them they gotta
lose 15 pounds they look at you like
it's a joke so we got rid of a lot of
excess weight we became very streamlined
but
the problem was and this is sort of the
backup plan was we were just going to
have to expand and grow a lot slower
yeah that's what was going to happen so
if we wouldn't have met good partners
who's out of new york great guys if we
wouldn't have met them we would have
done plan b and we would have you know
made some adjustments and it would have
been a slower growth
and the problem with that for me
is the same thing that i told the team
at taco fuel yesterday you know at
echelon front we go and we we go to the
muster and at the muster
we'll have
scores of people
come up to every team member to jp to
late to me to dave to everybody they'll
an individual come up and say oh you
know i hey i got my got my business back
we were about to go bankrupt we
recovered everything we're hiring now or
oh but i was about to get divorced and
my wife and i are back together and you
i
lost 58 pounds and just all these
incredible stories that you hear
and it sounds great but every muster
debrief
what i tell the team is hey great job
with this small number of people that we
helped with these principles and there
are literally millions and millions of
people that need
these principles to help them in their
life and we're not reaching them right
now so we're not doing what we should be
doing and it's the same thing with
jackal fuel right now right now as you
and i are sitting here talking there's a
22 year old kid that's drinking an
energy drink that's absolutely horrible
for him
that's that's what's happening there's
another
you know seven-year-old kid that's
drinking a chocolate milk that's filled
with high fructose corn syrup and it's
absolutely horrible for him and his mom
doesn't know his mom doesn't know what's
available so that's the issue so
as i you know as in my own mind you know
i had the the
part of my brain saying hey hang on we
can hang on and the other part of my
brain saying who are we hurting and the
compromise is okay how about and you
know what we eventually did is a
minority share we sold a minority share
brought in great partners that have
some great brands i mean they've they've
built and run some great companies i
mean just
um
outstanding so
that made it that that
that was nice it was like at the end of
wrestling season where all of a sudden
we'd have to cut weight every wednesday
and saturday yeah because we have some
room
i definitely saw the relief on the
finance team
don gut to sit back in his chair for
about five minutes and go ah you know
because being that lean and running just
in time inventory and at one point joe
moss our chief revenue officer said
man we're running this company with like
nine people and three bald dudes you
know you know
[Music]
basically me joe and brian there
whatever and you're looking at our
growth our growth rate and our
trajectory and it's like damn joe like
that's funny but it's it's right and you
know what
running the business like you're on a
desert island
is going to allow you there was you know
you would think
now you're going to be a good steward of
that investment
you know and i was talking to you about
as far as like living into the brand
like after that investment came on
i felt like i felt again that same kind
of like when i when when back in the day
when remortgaging the house for origin i
felt the same thing like man you know
some of our family and friends invested
in this in this with this alongside all
my
that's a broad statement but like a lot
of people that are very close to me
exactly
and i think that's important that like
this new partner allowed us to bring our
family and friends into him and my
childhood friend i've known since i was
12 years old invested in this thing you
know what i mean it's like man i better
i better be a good steward of this and
in in like i said live live into it you
know what i mean and you were like what
is live into it like well i'm gonna
i haven't been you know what i mean i
like them cookies and that ice cream
but uh well how well have you been
quote living into it this week dude
you're up here i've seen you consume
more
more cookies brownies have been what is
going on dude we've been living into
that jujitsu immersion bar
that you know late night cold cut combo
snack
in there dude but i mean you know like
is as far as understanding the psyche of
of the consumer of the people out there
because
i believe right now
and if you look at america
i think we're the strongest and
healthiest we've ever been and i think
we're the most unhealthy and most out of
shape determine america at large
people of america people and it's
probably a worldwide thing too but
we're you're there's some strong people
strongest they've ever we've ever been
100 percent healthiest we've ever been
and then
the heaviest and the most unhealthy
and people dying of all sorts of [__]
and there's this freaking gap
you know and yeah you can point the
finger but it the the finger goes in a
lot of different directions you gotta
have a lot of finger pointing
uh the fact of the matter is is we're
trying to fill the void between the two
you know and and educate people in a
different way
and
you know in in jocko fuel as a mission
as a movement in the things we're doing
it's no different than the origin side
you know origin built a belief built to
believe in the dream built to believe in
resurrection of america's factories and
communities and the reclamation and the
restoring and the restoring of the
communities and jackal fuel built to be
better you know it's the same damn thing
everything you wear everything you
consume like
it's it's right there you know what i
mean it's right there but then how do
you wedge that
in
into
this country which is not just divided
also from a health and physical
perspective it's divided so there's a
there's this education process that's
taking place and honestly taking on the
investment is going to allow us to do
more of this education across the board
so yeah and that was the point i was
getting at was like looking at weighing
between okay we can keep total control
and b be a little bit greedy
right and hang on this is mine or say
hey listen
let's get to as many people as we can so
we we made that adjustment and it's so
far it's been awesome it's been awesome
to have more freedom of movement for us
it's been awesome to still be able to
push forward in ways that we weren't
pushing forward before
and be able to execute on things that we
had we would have had to you know plan b
and plan c
didn't have the same
products coming out did we weren't able
to tackle the same problems that we're
going to be able to tackle now so
that that was awesome
as that's going on
meanwhile we
we expanded outside the state of maine
which i may have broke your heart
initially
because you're a maina i am a mainer
i'm actually a mass hole technically
father-in-law joe will never allow me to
claim he doesn't let you claim huh no
i'm i'm i'm from massachusetts man even
though i've been here since i was eight
years old
never a mana and your kids can't you
kids can't uh they think about that they
can't anchor baby you up here no i wish
nah but yeah i mean it you know like as
this is all going on
as we're going through the process of
investment and having all these meetings
and everything and at the same time
that's one monster
and and like needs attention and food
and money yes that's all going on
that's a huge
huge deal but then on the other side the
other monster the origin monster is also
hungry to your point earlier these
things are tangled like siamese twins
and these monsters are both they're
growing and they both need to be fed and
like someone has to conduct surgery like
yeah and just from another perspective
they're both
in being tangled
and being connected they're also
mutually supporting each other they
totally need each other and especially
or you know a year ago it was like
without one there really wouldn't be the
other one without the other there
wouldn't really be the ones so
so you had this the the one is eating
you know is eating big taking big bites
so the other one now the sudden you
start hearing uh like the stomach of the
other of the origin monster starts to
growl
yeah exactly and
you know we
i think in an effort to make sure we're
doing things right you know we made our
tuition payments on the origin side we
we built the things that built america
denim and boots we proved we could build
them again we we proved we could find
and reclaim the knowledge and make the
product
and and do it in a way that it was
profitable too
so we kind of have proved this out and
it's like okay it's time to go
you know and and if you're not growing
you're dying you know and that's one
thing i think in business
like people they get comfortable they
get complacent well listen if you're not
if you're not growing you're dying
because somebody's smarter than you is
behind you you know and
and with everything there's a beginning
there's a middle and there's an end and
trying to extend that middle part it's
not a coast it's not a flat road it's
not coasting i was telling somebody the
other day
you know you get to the top of that hill
when you're climbing you're pedaling and
pedaling and pedaling and you get to the
top and you think ah i get to coast on
the other side the thing is you get to a
plateau and then there's an incline on
that plateau you you can't see over the
horizon
and with origin we've been you know
we've kind of been playing in the
sandbox a little bit i
addressing the the team you know on the
inside you know kind of in the trenches
earlier this year was
this year
we start
i actually said to them we haven't done
anything yet
we're spread across 250 000 square feet
in two states and 400 people and we
haven't even started
like this [__] like we've been we've
been a research and development company
now it's time to go now it's time to
truly rebuild the supply chains and
build the products that we need and use
and wear so
i kind of you know like cast that wide
vision early in the year and
even even the constant touch point i
think still you know still
people it's almost like uh when you have
kids
you know
when i when i had my first child keegan
like amanda you know she's pregnant it's
like cool you know you're pregnant and
whatever and then then he came out and i
was like holy [__]
[Music]
what am i gonna do with this you know
what i mean like this is a this is a
real being that's kind of how i feel
like we're we're ready to like
go like there's like almost like a
little bit of a rebirth so to speak this
year
of what we're gonna do as a company as a
mission as a as a movement
and uh i i could see it i know you could
see it and i'm trying to explain it to
the team but they aren't they aren't
feeling it yet because it's all just
words
but we
just just i gotta throw this out there
yeah i'll go to talk to a gas oil
company in north dakota or i'll go talk
to an energy company in texas or go talk
to a
construction company in illinois or just
just and there'll be
a bunch of people that will show up with
they'll have origin jeans on they'll
have origin boots on
they're in the game they're so
supportive and so i think that
i get to see that right i get to see
people all over the country that are
that understand what we're doing and
they're so supportive of it
and i probably didn't do a great job of
you know i should be taking a picture
every time that happens you know and
sending it to you like hey show
everybody this picture i mean i've been
to events where there's like 12 people
come up and they're all wearing origin
jeans like how how awesome is that yeah
and you know this will be in the middle
of wherever oklahoma it's it's it's
awesome so yeah
you can start to you and i can sense all
that happening uh and probably need to
do a better job
making sure everybody on the team knows
that yeah and in there
you know it's interesting i know how to
look at this they're in the trenches
every day like making the stuff
answering the phone calls you know doing
the marketing and all that stuff
and
we're gonna build a hundred thousand
pairs of jeans right over the next 12
months and um and i'm down in tryon
georgia at mount vernon mills the oldest
mill in america in the last mil that
weaves denim
and they weave our denim for us
and i'm committing to 2 million yards in
three years
and i'm coming back and saying hey i
just committed to every single yard of
denim this milk can make
you know what i mean and they're like oh
okay
okay that's
this is like being in vegas man it's
just taking your wallet and putting it
on black 100
100 you know so there's
there's like how are we going to fill
the gap how are we going to go from
point a to point b
and speaking of feeding the monsters oh
we're going to build 100 000 pairs of
jeans and in three years we're gonna
build a million
you know and on the jocko fuel side oh
we're making 30 000 cases of this a
month and we need to get to 200 000 in
three years you have these two
these two monsters that you actually
know like the
what they're gonna eat yeah you know
that you know the cons that you you use
the baby assumption the consumption rate
you know how much freaking milk it's
gonna take to get these kids to be full
grown that's right and so you need to
plan for it yep and you know at some
point they're gonna be a 16 and a half
year old boy and they're gonna have a
voracious appetite
exactly and it's gonna be nuts so we
actually know that we can plot it out we
can see it
and so that so that's
as you look at that growth and the
amount of
effort it was going to take for them the
amount of uh
work that was going to take to get done
you knew that we were going to reach our
limit here in maine 100
yep and just walking around the factory
and just we have pivoted and pivoted and
pivoted and pivoted and gotten leaner
and leaner and leaner and leaner i mean
you got to remember in that in our first
little you know
our first big factory after we left the
woods
right like when you came on board and we
partnered up we were still in the woods
and we're like we're going to build
we're going to buy this big building
like 20 000 square feet
where where at one point jocko fuel
literally was on pallets in between all
the sewing machines yeah so just so
people understand how
these things were tangled
and so we we moved into that building
2000 2017 july and
when we did that we had 12 employees
yeah 12 12 employees i mean it was cool
it was cool and you walked around it was
like okay cool we got like plenty of
room to grow right oh we got plenty of
room to grow not so much not so much
so you know there's a you know just
walking around and thinking
this is this is not going to sustain us
in looking at the kind of stepping back
out of the trenches looking at the
battlefield going how are we going to go
from you know point a to point b
when it comes to knitwear when it comes
to hoodies when it comes to t-shirts
when it comes to denim when it comes to
all the things we need to make
we're going to have to look elsewhere
closer to supply chains
knowing that what we're really good at
in maine is building ultra durable goods
like footwear and jiu jitsu
and that
the cotton supply chain the weaving and
the dying
is all more down in the in north
carolina in georgia
louisiana you know south carolina
is there opportunity down there
and we found some opportunity
so
we
we found a company that uh
would was gonna cut and sew for us
and
man they were starting to work on some
projects for us and i remember just
calling you and being like
oh
we gotta try and buy this place
like walking into that for the first
time and seeing it three times bigger
than what we're doing and just cranking
stuff out i was like oh man god like you
don't know what you don't know you know
and i actually say that to my kids like
hey you know you don't you don't know
what you don't know
um and you can't control what you can't
control but you can respond you can you
can control the way you respond to
things you can't control well we can
respond to the things we don't know we
can control the way we respond to it you
know and
try not to have an entrepreneurial
seizure at the same time
uh which you know
we had some opportunities to have i
think but uh
we bought
two factories let's let's talk through
the first one yeah right so it's 60 000
square feet
you roll down there there's not a for
sale sign on it no it's not for sale you
know what i'm saying like this isn't
like uh you go on a used car lot there's
a used you know uh cut and so factory
for sale and you hey hey how much is
this and you no that that's not how it
worked no and these in in like they
barely have a website i mean you know
there's like all these old little old
factories spread across america that are
still there that have been surviving
they have not thrived they're not a
thriving factories they've been
surviving for the last 25 years
out of a sheer like force of will right
whether a commitment to the people who
have been working there for 25 30 years
you know or or not knowing enough to
shut it down or being too um
i don't know what the word is honoring
stubborn yeah yeah to shut it down
so
luckily i was able to go chaotic too
patriotic patriotics a better word yeah
i mean
yeah so
went and met with this old boy ted
hasn't was going through some health
problems
kind of sold him on the vision of course
you know
they are looking at a yankee
mm-hmm
this yankee coming down
and there's still some of that there you
know what i mean like even jason has
said to me you know y'all rachel
yankee's coming down here
bro you kidding me when we started this
company we didn't have two nickels to
rub together a bucket to piss in bro
like
like go onto youtube and watch how we
built this thing
so but it's still like these yankees
coming down and whatever so
you know went down there
met with ted
told him what we'd like to do to carry
on his his vision and plan for the
company obviously he had a great
operator down there and jason gaddy
great operator who's been doing this
thing and he's really the one that's
been sustaining this organization for a
long time you know 120 employees
whatever it is and just cutting and
sewing just ripping stuff out making
stuff for some pretty substantial brands
too
um
but you know it's one of those
situations where
like okay this guy's kind of like
a lot of talk
they're thinking you're a lot of talk
yeah yeah i think so and it's tough
you've got this
you've got these people who have been
running this business for 40 50 years
they've owned it for 40 50 years they do
things a certain way they have a certain
culture there's a certain pace there's a
certain vibe
you know and and just somebody coming in
that could potentially disrupt that is
scary yeah you know you i mean
you're ultimately people are innately
afraid of the unknown you know it's also
what also drives some people
um
but
i i asked him and and convinced him and
not just him i flew
him up to maine
and showed him our little factory
and showed him what we were doing and
introduced him to the people
introduced him to amanda
obviously turned him on to jocko like
you know of course
they know who you are anyways so just
kind of made that connection that always
helps there's always like you've got
plan you've got like the the deco says
this like when somebody comes to his
school right uh uh dodeco wanna you know
one of my our business partners also my
jiu-jitsu instructor
uh he's got a school down in
massachusetts in weymouth and when
people come in they like oh i want to
start jiu jitsu and they were like okay
cool oh oh origen geese
oh i've heard i think i've heard this
company origin it's like yeah man yeah
origin you know origin and then they're
like oh wait
jocko
and he's like yeah yeah
you know he's he's also my business
partner my friend or whatever and then
they sign up right away so it's the
ringer right like jock was the ringer
and every negotiation i just pull i pull
jocko's name and it always it always
helps so
um you know we we flew him up to maine
we flew up uh
i know who else we flew up
the head stitcher
and the mechanic yeah
and that's one of those hearts and minds
campaign hearts and minds man and
getting to build relationships with
people and getting them to understand
what what we understand yes
i want the mechanic to meet our team and
to watch them sell
that's what i want him to do so he can
say to ted the owner
hey these guys are for real they know
what they're doing i get what they're
doing their head stitcher i wanted her
to watch the way we sewed
the the way the hands moved so that she
could feel confident in the same thing
that you know we're
we are who they are we're not just
yankees we are people who are trying to
rebuild the middle class who are
retraining and bringing this thing back
the same thing they've been doing for 30
40 years
luckily
they agreed to it and we made that [__]
happen was there a turning point that
you saw was there a moment or was it a
gradual uh swaying of the mindset
well there was there was a tricky
situation there right he had a couple
other partners
and
they they had a a kind of an aggressive
ask initially
you know
like you said earlier
i don't have my business degree
i try to understand people i'm i'm
pretty transparent in negotiation like i
i wear my heart on my sleeve i'm not
hiding anything and
i explained to him in their first ask i
was like yeah it's just not we're just
not there like it we're just not there
like here's the value of what we're
gonna do because we're not gonna buy
this business as a business entity and
keep like just running the same way with
the same accounts we're gonna buy this
as an extension of origin that's it's
going to be a it's going to be a
production facility ultimately for
origin so
the the revenue doesn't really matter
what's important is you have 120 people
who know how to make badass [__] badass
durable [__] and you have the machines
to do so so the value is in the people
because you can buy machines so you're
buying people
you're buying a skill set you're buying
a capability
and to try to to try to ramp up 120
people and turn that on
we've already done it it took it took
freaking a decade to do the same thing
we don't have a decade so we got to buy
capacity so we're buying capacity i
explained that to him unpack that for
him and ultimately we came to agreement
and
you know when you when when you talk
about like putting money where your
mouth is like me you and deco stroke to
check and bought that place like that's
like we're talking about we're
reinvesting in
america's communities that wasn't a bank
loan on that one we wrote a check and
i think that that was also
meaningful to them knowing yeah we got
to go finance this thing like we're not
a hedge fund coming in you know we're
not corporate raiders coming in
you know we're we're actually investing
in this personally our families are
investing in what your family has built
um pushed him over got the deal done
and you know we're high-fiving we just
added 120 people who know how to build
that as [__]
but it still wasn't enough
yeah and in the meantime you know we we
kind of breezed through the
the getting the the partnership with
good partners
um one thing that was interesting about
that was
a lot of the stuff that i think would
make a lot of companies
really sweat and have to work like for
instance you know our our financials
right so don
our cfo
he's been here and he we were so dialed
in you know despite all the
all the overwork that he had done you
know by himself much of the time
a lot of times and look uh luckily for
me on the echelon front side i'm
i'm a
party to a lot of these deals you know i
see a lot of pes come in i watch these
deals happen i'm part of these deals
sometimes so i've seen a lot of this and
it was awesome because sometimes you
know it you start asking when they start
doing the financial due diligence
you know it's it's like open up a can of
worms and mayhem's coming out and it
gets crazy and it was awesome
to and i remember you and i have this
conversation you know like hey you know
i said hey what are we looking like from
the financial side as they're rolling
this due diligence how long do you think
it's gonna take and you're like hey man
you know the deal like we it's not gonna
take long and there's
it's it's all just good to go and so i
thought that that was
pretty awesome especially considering
such a small team
of one much of the time you know of just
don
being that squared away
and and he had done a lot to
prepare us for that uh so
that was that was pretty awesome and
finding
those guys
you know i i'd say
that if people aren't alive though the
one the one time that you're gonna have
a failure is if we aren't aligned if two
people aren't aligned or if two teams
aren't aligned you're gonna have you're
gonna ultimately have failure because
you can't be going to two different
places you have to be going to the same
place if you can't break the laws of
physics and go to two different places
you can't rip bodies apart it doesn't
work
and so luckily
with good partners you know they had
they had built supreme they'd built
skull candy uh they got saved companies
yeah dave they got up hook the huk hook
performance fishing like really great
companies that are cool
and so they had experience with this
stuff and they were able to address
things with us and talk about where we
wanted to go and what you know
here's here's something that was
tricky i was tricky
because i
i don't like to lock things in because i
don't know what the future holds i give
this advice all the time hey you know
what the future's going to hold so why
are you locking in this or that and so
the way we set things up and the way
they
that they worked with us was like oh we
have all kinds of options we have all
kinds of directions to go into there's
no doors closed so that was great how
flexible they were they were patient as
hell yeah they were patient they were
patient bro at some point sometimes like
i my ass was stuck to my couch you know
and i i would be like on the phone on
the phone on the phone on the phone like
till midnight yeah it was it was
honestly it was like uh
this kind of
this uh i don't know the word for it
this constant
alignment yeah constant alignment and
having the right like the right words
yeah you know what i mean and sometimes
those words were tricky to
yeah tricky
tricky here's something else that was
cool and it's a good this is a good
this is a good lesson learned um for
anybody that's out there uh lawyers
talking to each other suck is different
than two people talking to each other
yes so i remember we were
you know we'd hit a little bit of a uh
let's say a little
a little hesitation right
i was a little bit hesitant it sounded
like they so my lawyers are telling me
that they're saying this and their
lawyers are telling their crew that that
i'm saying this and finally
uh i'm like dude give me dave's number
and like we just got on the phone and
i'm like hey this is what i'm worried
about he goes yeah we can handle that
that's no factor i don't wanna you know
that doesn't make a difference okay cool
great write it up like this he's like
cool i got it he said hey but jocko you
you gotta give me this over here and i'm
like oh yeah that totally makes sense i
don't you know you're not gonna you're
not gonna give us money
if you don't have this type of thing so
once he and i talked person to person
man to man and just oh yeah hey man okay
cool
from there it was like everything was
fine yeah but there was that getting to
that whole time though that monster was
kept eating oh it kept beating dude
everything in sight and you know i you
know i you were sweating yeah oh yeah i
was definitely you were sweating and
you'd talk to me like bro uh
you're you know you're trying to like
talk to the both sets of lawyers and i'm
like bro let me talk to dave let's get
this thing and so luckily
you know uh
when you talk and you're aligned
then it's easy and look look hey this is
another thing to remember when you when
someone else is when the opposing lawyer
is looking out for them and your
lawyer's looking out for you
they're they're not they're not trying
to go to the same place no they're
trying to go to two different places so
they're gonna have a hard time so you
have to have sometimes conversations and
those conversations need to be backed up
in writing of course that's why so so
you can then debrief the lawyers and the
lawyers understand where you're where
you need to be and that both sides have
agreed
so
that's something to remember
and
here's another uh
you know you and i never
freaking had lawyers in between us you
know what i mean no we didn't and the
other funny thing i was telling people
this the other day is we never had we
were we were on a handshake for
for years on a handshake millions and
millions of dollars worth of business
uh tens of millions tens of millions of
dollars worth of business on a handshake
on a handshake absolutely which is
freaking awesome yeah like old school i
hope people can learn from that and by
the way the only reason we eventually
like okay we need to we need to go to
paper on this stuff is because the banks
and the lawyers were like hey
guys this thing's too big this doesn't
work you can't have a handshake like if
one of you dies if one of you dies this
is a freaking disaster for all involved
and we're like alright fine
so
we did it but that but that was a
you know that was great i was i was
definitely like sweating it and i'll
tell you what i gotta give kip uh props
on it because
he kept telling me pete you gotta
understand something all big fish are
lost at the boat
you can reel and reel and reel and reel
and reel and you go to grab that gill
and pull that hook and you lose it you
know what i mean like you get it right
to the boat and it flaps its tail and
rips off
and we were at tail flapping
kind of scenario at that point and i'm
trying to hang on to the freaking guilt
yeah you know what i mean yeah like uh
trying to grab the club
to kill this thing
but it was uh ultimately i think
i think that there they were
definitely not only the right partner
but the patient partner we need yep
you know that was that was a nice
uh let's say you know it proved to me as
they were waiting
you know they're like okay
they didn't they didn't freak out they
didn't get crazy they weren't like all
this they were like oh it's going to
take some time to get this thing worked
out you know it's like
oh she doesn't want to marry me right
now yeah yeah no it's like she wants to
wait another year and most private
equity firms would not have done that
yeah yeah so they were super cool and
proved the type of people that they were
through their actions which was legit
yeah and so
that worked out great and has been great
um
in the meantime right
we get
how long was it
once we had
the factory in north carolina the first
factor in north carolina okay factory
one we get that next over so just after
we recorded the last podcast we're going
to go first on it so
we're stoked
how long did the stoke last before you
start
you started hearing hunger growls from
the monster again one month it was one
month yeah because we we launched
november we launched our our black
friday we do that like one deal a year
and bro we sold like 10 000 pairs of
jeans yeah that's right we had to close
it off and like like i don't know a
thousand two thousand pairs of boots and
i'm i'm looking at you i remember you
texting me like we're shutting it down
yeah and that's when i was like
okay that's that always sucks bro you
know because what that means is someone
out there is gonna have to buy a pair of
jeans that are made in another country
and that that's horrible it's horrible
for america it's horrible for our
economy it's horrible for our community
it's horrible for the person that has to
wear
sub-standard jeans on their body
and yet you know i remember hey we have
to shut this down right now and i'm
thinking damn
the immediate pivot was i remember
sitting down the day the next business
day after black friday
with the team and saying
what are we going to do how are we going
to pivot
and we got jason on the phone our you
know new partner down in north carolina
running all north carolina operations
and i said hey bro
i think we can make jeans there remember
this yeah
i'm like they're
i think i mean i think we can but these
machines are completely different
fouling machines
he's like yeah we can get it done we get
it done
and immediately and i think that's the
great thing with
obviously owning
your supply chain i you know i like to
call it the origin factory blockchain i
use the word blockchain because people
understand what a blockchain is these
days well the origin factory blockchain
is a blockchain of manufacturing and
transparency where you can trust where
everything comes from you know that
cotton's come from texas you know that
thing's woven in try on georgia you know
it's getting cut and sewn in north
carolina in maine and it's a blockchain
of manufacturing which is really
powerful and it's actually core to who
we are in quarter our story because we
got nothing to hide we ain't cutting out
tags right we're making the [__] from
scratch and
you know we actually
put out there to the public like we're
gonna have to make jeans in north
carolina and watch us pivot and also
follow us as we make mistakes you know
and make tuition payments but
that mechanic that we flew up to maine
used to work in a denim factory
and he knew how to set up the machines
down there and he knew how to tune them
in and he had all the beautiful tooling
made
it was
actually it was so good he made more and
sent it to maine so we could use it in
maine so we made the pivot it wasn't
easy but we got it done and and we're
still not producing enough and i
remember
saying to i don't know if i called you
while we were down there getting to know
the area this is asheboro north carolina
i drove by a building
in it and it said on a trailer outside
of the building it said texas jeans on
it
and i remember just asking jason like
what is that he's like oh that's uh this
old guy
wally
and he's been in the denim business
for
ever
come to find out and i didn't know this
i learned that north carolina was the
denim capital of america
and i'm like so he's like he's got like
denim machines and people making jeans
in there and everything he's like yeah
so
again another situation
we leaned into it a little bit
knocked on literally knocked on the door
went in
and
started having a conversation it all
started with a conversation
i know i know when you're talking about
going back to factory one
jason gaddy all right
you got this guy i just wanna i wanna
kind of profile him just for a minute
was did you see a transition in his
because look the only jason i've known
is 100
let's make some [__] happen now we got
this here's what we need to do that's
the only jason i know was that the only
jason you know was that was that a
turnaround
was there a turning point for him where
where he realized
that this was the right thing to do
because i mean like i said i've seen
nothing but jason
nothing from jason except for
like a 100
positive awesome attitude to make things
happen and also be like no hey we we're
not gonna be able to do that or if we're
gonna do that here's what we're gonna
need like that kind of thing
was he like that the whole time i would
say
his level of positivity was always
consistent nice and if and if there was
anything he was feeling he did
definitely didn't show it now with that
said we had a lot of private
conversations a lot of private
conversations
he educated me on the way they survived
over the past 30 years he educated me on
the restructuring they had to go through
the banks coming in and pulling apart
the company and putting it back together
and putting a ceo in place and how he
fell in you know like like they had they
went through some [__] man like after
nafta and the wto like they went through
some serious [__] and he was part of it
so there's this protective kind of
defense mechanism there that you know
he's looking out for his people
and again
regardless of you know
the this newfound relationship
and working towards this kind of new
culture
you're still blending two cultures
together and two companies together
so there was definitely some
apprehension behind the scenes and we
had lots and lots of in-depth
conversations some intense conversations
too
the the good thing with him is
like he's
he's the type of guy and and maybe at
some point it'd be good to have him on
the podcast but he's the type of guy
that he's a he's just he's a survivor
man that i was gonna throw that surprise
you talk about all these restructurings
and all these things going on and
putting the news and he's the guy that's
there he's there and and he's been
through some [__] in his life and in you
know and he's he's he's a survivor so
that's
it's tough
when you have built something for so
long
to then i'm just gonna say abandon it
you've been building this thing for 20
30 years and some freaking yankee
is coming down asking you to abandon it
because that's ultimately the end goal
right is you're you're gonna abandon
this and and you're gonna and i'm asking
you to fully buy into what we're doing
unproven
completely unproven just from watching
some freaking youtube videos and knowing
you know jocko's my other partner
[Music]
it's still still even though you can you
can buy into that and you can trust it
your your livelihood and all these
people's livelihood you're you're
betting you're betting that we're going
to do the right thing
without that trust and that bond being
built uh so yeah
another comment i make a lot when i'm
working with companies is
you know they say well you know you guys
were in the single teams and you're
dealing with life life and death and
you'd be dealing with people's lives and
i always say you know we dealt with
people's lives you deal with people's
livelihoods
and that's the thing about jason you
could tell
that total positive attitude you could
also see
that
like
that family attitude towards his people
that he wanted to take care of his
people like he needed to survive because
that meant his people would survive yeah
like you could feel that when you talk
to him yeah he's a he's intense and
you know thank god he was willing to go
to a muster
and he went to that muster and it
changed his life
he literally said pete
i have learned more about myself
and i'm growing every day man you know
in his his thick southern accent
and uh you know jp took him under his
wing and
a couple other you know the instructors
and
really dug in with him they dug in
and and kind of
i don't want to say like remolded but
remolded the way he thinks and is
walking through life
and thinking about business and
that was so important honestly if he
didn't go to that muster
i don't know
i don't know where we'd be right now if
he didn't go to that muster well as we
get into the next factory you can see
like i would be observing and going oh
yeah he's got this he understood he
understands this part he understands
that part he understands this concept he
understands that concept you could see
that i could see that
and and believe me i i look at this
stuff all day long i look at meetings
all day long i sit with companies all
day long i sit in boardrooms all day
long i go to manufacturing floor that's
what i do all day yeah yeah so for me
sitting there watching this like oh okay
i can see when people are disconnected i
can see when they don't understand
what's happening i can see when when
there's some agendas that they're i can
see all that and you didn't see it at
all from him i i saw that he did and
what's cool too
is survivor being a survivor we say that
as a positive thing right
but
we also know that and just like any
other characteristic if someone's a
survivor and that's kind of they get in
that survivor mode it can be an absolute
negative because they're trying to
survive and they're not trying to grow
and they're not trying to thrive yes
which is problematic and so i i think
that transition from him just going hey
i'm just going to make sure i take care
of what i've got right now into a growth
mindset and a thrive mindset of oh
we can actually not just survive but
actually grow and take over and and
crush
i think that was a pretty awesome
transition for for jason gaddy to make
yeah it was it was so now you're driving
around asheboro north carolina
shout out
and you drive by this building yeah and
you see a trailer sitting and by the way
it's a big building yeah it's a huge
building but it's very nondescript
yeah it's nondescript it's got this
trailer with the texas jeans and and
just in terms of timeline here
we like i had seen
i had seen this building during the deal
making for that first factory
i had seen it and you mean driven by it
yeah just look at that yeah yeah and
actually i think uh
i think we tried to get in but we
weren't able to
like the guy there was just not
interested in talking to us or anything
so it was kind of a blip right it was
like uh it's like oh we you know what
what's that you know like and kind of a
blip try to get couldn't get it whatever
so um
it came back up and i i had remembered
oh there's this thing so drove back by
it called jason
do you
do you know who owns this do you have
the contact information is there any way
we can talk and you know jason's like
yeah i know who it is
you know basically like good luck you
know what i mean with this whole thing
and i said well
we're making jeans in maine we're making
jeans in north carolina things are
working
but
at the pace we're selling right at the
pace of product that we're selling
because we're we're a company that
literally we we take an order in and we
manufacture the thing so we're selling
you know a thousand pairs a week right
now on top of the 10 000 in back order
so we're now pushed out from black
friday we're pushed out for five months
which is completely unacceptable it's
completely unacceptable in this world of
getting [__] from amazon dropped in by a
drone
right like an hour after you order of it
so
it just was like i i kind of looked at
the numbers and the in the run rate of
what we were selling and i'm like it
just sounds like this ain't happening it
just doesn't work you remember that
phone call yeah like hey we
we're not going to be able to ever
produce what we need to produce at this
run rate with this kind of growth
trajectory so
jason connected
me with the son of the owner
the son of the owner connected me with
the owner
again
not for sale
he entertained me
he entertained me in this old 1970s
boardroom
that had a distinct smell to it
him and his wife dolores
um
and i could tell this dude was hard
you know like just
the way he carried himself the way he
looked at me
the way he interacted
he even told me if i was your age i
would kick your ass
he said i would kick your ass and i'd
kick your ass in business you couldn't
touch me
you can't compete with me you don't know
what i know
what i've done out in this plant i went
out in the plant he actually did bring
me out in the plant for a couple minutes
and i asked the son if i could shoot
photos and he's like yeah go ahead and
then he saw me shooting photos and he
said to jason gaddy goes if i see that
dude shoot another photo i'm gonna
kneecap him right here
i mean that's the type of dude we're
dealing with
j just to just to put this in in a
little bit of perspective
so this guy how how long have he been in
this business for about 50 years so
if you don't know this
if you don't know this this is
this is the old school um
way
and back in the day
well look at the history 50 years this
is when you had the
like union issues this is when you
anti-union issues this is when you had
massive influence from organized crime
in the textile industry like
this is when you had intense intense
competition in america because this is
before everything's overseas so now
you're now you've got in like the most
intense competition
and this guy you want to talk about a
survivor and a thriver this is a guy
that dominated
and dominated for 50 years
and worked and if you were not a badass
you weren't gonna make it it wasn't
gonna happen and if you weren't a badass
you were gonna get your ass kicked and
that's what he did
he went around that's why he was you
know
the the last
standing wash house the last
denim plant
from the the golden age of textiles in
america this is the guy the last
standing guy
right that's it the last one i mean
you're talking about a plant that's a
hundred and seventy thousand square feet
with this wash house now
a storage room
right with these big 500 pound washing
machines that tip forward dump out you
know the the wash jeans
truck bro that hasn't been dumped like a
dump truck that haven't been running
they're not the washing machines don't
weigh 500 pounds they wash 500 pounds
you know a quarter ton worth of jeans
yeah they're nine feet tall they're
i don't know how many thousands of
pounds they're massive massive machines
but you know you walk into this place
and you could just tell it's like uh
man like world war ii post-world war ii
east germany berlin like everything's
just so closed and dark and dank and it
just had this it had a survivor type of
feeling like this thing exists out of
out of sheer survival like it shouldn't
exist
it shouldn't be here it should have been
gutted and turned into something else a
long time ago
and this guy was not willing to let it
go just force of will yep just a sheer
force of will so how did you
uh uh navigate the conversation
to go from this isn't for sale
and if you put your don't put your
camera away i'm going to kneecap you
right here
how do you transition from that
to
let's just i mean how do you even get
him to open his mind a little bit well
let's
let's just say that
it didn't start off great
in it and ultimately it ended up good
but
the ebbs and flows of our conversations
in what transpired during this time
was
not only the strangest
negotiation i've ever been part of
but even more of one of the more
heartfelt too you know what i mean it
was it was a hard negotiation it was
hard to talk to him it was hard to find
common ground
because of his passion and our passion
for what we're doing
i think ultimately
he saw something
that he was willing to believe in a
spark of something and
not to get ahead of myself here but
the first time he walked in i had jason
with me
and while he walks in you know and he's
kind of he's got his kind of the brows
over his eyes and he kind of walks in
and his wife's behind him and jason's
like what up old timer and um and and
wally looked at jason and you could tell
they probably had competed in the past
or
you know whatever you got you got two
strong
southern men right
and wally said something smart to jason
like i'll kick your ass or something
like that i was just like i literally
put my head in my hand going oh man
how is this gonna go
you know the what it boiled down to was
he's in bad health and right now wally
is he's actually not doing good i i
actually wanted to interview him for the
documentary we've been working on and
i've asked three times i've talked to
him i've talked to his wife and at this
point i'm probably annoying about it but
he won't do it and
he said to me because i remember things
a certain way
and
somebody else remember remembers them
another way
and
i can respect that but some of the
stories he told me which i i can't share
i can share some of them but
are
unbelievable straight out of a movie you
know with organized crime and all that
all that stuff
but ultimately we spent
20 hours over the course of a few weeks
in that boardroom talking and
negotiating
he started the negotiation with
you are not seeing my books you are not
seeing my financials
if you want to get this thing done
he's like you're gonna number one have
to tell me why because i got somebody
ready to stroke me a check right now
and that's the person i'm going to sell
it to
that's how the negotiation started
there were times
where it this wasn't happening
well let me let me first start off by
saying this when you first called me
about what it was what the opportunity
was i was like oh this is next level you
know you're talking about an incredible
staff of people that have an incredible
skill set an incredible
amount of machinery
a space that's hundred and seventy
thousand square feet
a space that's grandfathered for as far
as like a wash house you can't build a
wash house like that you can't do it
anymore there was there are things that
are once in a lifetime yes this was a
once in a lifetime opportunity so i was
and you know of course you're telling me
hey man we're the the the jeans thing
that we're doing right now we
we we are not going to be able to do
this
and then all of a sudden here comes like
a a ray of light right like like a like
a lifeboat like divine intervention yeah
you're drowning you're you're you're in
the ocean you're you're alive but
you're
you're in the ocean yeah and all of a
sudden a lifeboat comes
and this thing was like a lifeboat and
so i'm
super stoked and
you know you can always make deals
happen right you can always make deals
happen you always figure out a way and
my attitude is always
well we'll figure out a way to make a
deal we'll make a deal
and there was some times in this where
we weren't making a deal where
it wasn't happening where i just thought
yeah man what are we going to do now i
was in plan b c d because
you'd say hey
let me debrief you on what just happened
today
you know and i'd be like okay
the deal fell apart
completely
multiple times and then it would come
back together yep and then it would fall
apart but it wasn't like uh it didn't
seem like
those deals falling apart were any
negotiation it seemed like it just died
like it wasn't like oh you know he's
hardballing us or he's gonna hold a
little bit or we gotta come back with a
different number number it was like no
you know what i'm actually just not
selling this to you anymore yeah he
didn't even he he honestly didn't care
about
what we were going to pay for
it didn't really have anything to do
with money
he wanted someone
tough that wasn't me by the way
he wanted someone tough
who
could come in there
and demand respect
that
knew how to interact with people
that understood the business
that could carry on his legacy
and after 20 hours of negotiation that
wasn't me and i'll share with you in a
second who it was
at that at that table that conference
table and flying back and forth and
having these meetings
i did learn something very important
about negotiation
in negotiation with
someone who is so passionate
about something that they've been
building for 40 50 years 50 years
remember this guy had seven plants
around north carolina he made it through
the exportation
of
our jobs and machinery and the abandoned
communities he he survived it
you know the other thing is is
this this guy
i don't know it's he's the last of his
kind
i think is what it boils down to
and he doesn't really believe that
anyone can do what he does you ever met
somebody like that there is nobody alive
that can do what i did what i do
he made the genes for levi's he made the
genes for wrangler he made the genes for
calvin klein on one case he shared with
me he was he got a contract for calvin
klein and a guy showed up in his office
unannounced
his secretary comes to see him hey
there's somebody here to see you
and he's like okay
and
the guy comes in his office and he puts
two plane tickets on his desk tells him
you know where
i know where you live
i know you know
i i know everything about you basically
you're coming with me
and on the other end of those tickets
was a guy named whitey bulger
wally's like hold on a second
tells the guy to chill out for a second
gets on the phone
calls a friend to his up in new york
city
saying hey i got a guy here named whitey
bulger
he's like
he's asking me to pay money he said wait
wally hold on
who he's like whitey bulger he goes
who are you making jeans for he says
calvin klein
he goes i'll call you back in 15 minutes
come to find out his friend had the
connections
i don't even know if i should be sharing
this [__] bro
his friend had the connections to get to
the top
and uh
whitey
basically he gets a phone call back and
they're like is mr bulger there
puts him on the phone with mr bulger
and whitey's he said i just heard the
guy go yup yup
yup got it okay puts the phone down and
leaves
he wasn't paying
for every pair of jeans that he was
making
he wasn't given the cut wasn't given the
cut he didn't know he was supposed to be
given the cut it had never filtered down
to him
so he started receiving checks with the
cut taken out for the product there was
a lot of stories like this there was
some pretty there were some stories that
he was telling me and i think the point
is is he wanted me to know how tough he
was
you know here's a here's a here's a guy
who's at end of life
you know it's actually kind of it's kind
of sad too he's at end of life he's
built this empire he's invested
everything in this
he's the best in the world at it
he's in the best in the world at making
denim blue jeans
and he's staring
at
death
we spent a week negotiating two weeks
negotiating and then it's just radio
silence there's there's no more
conversation
i'm trying to figure out what's going on
i i think the deal's done man i think
it's dead there's no more conversation
there was another entity
another entity that one was the first
one that had a ton of money
you know backed by
massive massive hundreds of millions of
dollars and they were ready to roll in
there
i finally get on the phone with his wife
dolores got her cell phone number she
sounds pretty wound up
you know hey while he's you know he's
he's in hospital you know
um
why don't you come down next week
so i go back down i'm sitting in the
boardroom wally comes in and he sits
down you know and he's looking rough and
he
he's welling up you know what i mean
he's just he's welling up in his eyes
and i'm like
what's going on and he basically said
nobody knows this i haven't even shared
it with my son
but
he he had a heart attack in
he died
called i guess his wife called
they brought him back to life
got him back and they actually said
there is no way you should be alive
right now
you must have more to do
and that was the defining moment where
he opened up back for negotiation where
where he just he was staring death in
the face and then he dies
he gets brought back to life
and now i'm sitting in a board with with
him
and i have my wife next to me
amanda and i knew bringing her down
was gonna be
important because
him and his wife have been doing this
thing and they've been a unit you know
they've just
they're like-minded in in one place off
the other one and similar to the way
amanda is in and i am
and
it was then that he decided that we had
what it took that i didn't have what it
took but that she had what it took
because he was asking he asked me
actually asked me to bring her down
i said amanda i want to bring out north
carolina listen wally's asking asking to
meet you i go why do i need to go she's
like this is your thing this is what you
do i said i don't know i said he wants
he wants to meet you
and he in in i called him back yeah i'm
going to be coming down he's like you're
going to bring amanda right and i'm like
yes i'm going to bring amanda
he's he stared at me across the table
and he said he said to me he goes he's
like you can't do this he goes i don't
trust you can do it he goes but she can
i watch the way she moves i watch the
way she walks i watch the way she
interacts i said she can make this
happen
and i wouldn't do a deal with you but
i'll do a deal with her
and i said
you're right
yeah
you're right man i know man i agree with
wally bro 100
it's like
you're right and you know and that was
the turning point man the guy died got
brought back to life he saw his legacy
in front of him he saw you know a
a family and i'm talking about a family
he's he's of course the jocko thing came
into play because he had a special
forces guy that lives next door to him
who told him all about you so you've got
people who are hungry to bring back
manufacturing in america it was at that
point
that he believed that we could carry on
his legacy and things move forward
and and bro like
even with even his belief that it could
move forward that we could handle it was
still
it was still just the beginning of all
the [__] that we had to go through
to make the deal happen
well one thing i remember
another point
was
there was
you you called me up and you're like hey
it ain't happening or you send me a text
like it ain't happening and i'm like oh
you know what oh
so we get on the phone
and
you're like hey we're we're do you know
we're going through the the uh the due
diligence and whatnot and there's no
phase two environmental study hasn't
been done in 30 years or whatever 40
years
and you're like hey man
if this comes up bad
we could be out
a million two million dollars worth of
like cleanup and repair and payments
and you're like we just you we just
don't know
and
i remember i'm like okay
i said hey man how much would it cost us
to build that factory
and you're like
i don't know you're like uh you're
running the numbers you're like 25
20 25 maybe 30 million and i go
let's do this deal and you're like roger
that you know cause
and that's again that's one of those
things where you were really close to
the deal of course
but i looked at you know that's actually
a small risk when you put it up against
what we would have had to have done and
i mean and look even if we had a a
billion dollars
to say okay now go build that factory
how long does that take now go get those
people where do you get them from now
train those people years it's it's it's
maybe seven years like literally seven
years if we had a billion dollars it
would have taken seven years yeah so
those little risks those additional
risks that you take because it's a once
in a lifetime it
this is a once in a lifetime deal
yeah it is uh
it's it shouldn't it shouldn't have
existed and it shouldn't have happened
one one person sheer force of will to
hang on to what
to the golden age of manufacturing
one person's decision is actually
going to spearhead this renaissance this
revolution of manufacturing
we're we're actually just dovetailing
onto that right to carry it forward he
was like the underground resistance for
40 years yes just like sitting in a cave
keeping those machines on just keeping
it going and everybody i come in contact
with like
everybody i came in contact with since
then
has said oh you you're you know you're
the owner of the new uh of wally's
factory i said yeah and they're like i
can't believe you got that done with
wally
like i mean everybody knows the guy and
he's he's a hard ass man dude's a hard
ass but
ultimately
it got done we got it done
freaking sign the paper yeah we we got
it done when they're like uh one of his
stipends right again this whole thing
was like a cliffhanger yeah right hey
okay i want the money in a week that's
yeah
the guy's crazy man
he's crazy
or did we escrow him some funds or
i mean i remember wiring big
fat numbers around and going yeah yeah
and here's the other thing like you kind
of breeze through this but you can't see
my books and you can't see my financials
no you he actually had a piece of like
just uh notebook paper
and he wrote on his revenue what he did
he's like this is how much i pay for
heat
this is how much
this is this is my payroll
here's
lights electric
he goes and here's um the revenue and
you can see this is how this is the math
works
and that's cool you're like hey roger
that you should you sent me a text of a
napkin or whatever like hey this is what
we're buying
according to the napkin i think i think
most people walking in there would would
be like this is
like this guy's crazy yeah like this is
a [__] yeah you know in in
i think it's the future yeah and i think
you know
thankfully you had the understanding of
the true value and i think you know just
like every good deal like he
he got
he got what he wanted yeah he really did
a a team that's gonna come on board
that's gonna continue that fight that's
going to expand that fight
and that's what he wanted
you know and then
all parties can walk away feeling good
about the deal that's a great deal
when that happens
and then
it's like you finally get to go into the
factory for the first time
and you know this is like buying this is
like buying a car this is like walking
up seeing a car in the parking lot and
the guy's like hey i'll sell you that
car over on the other side of the
parking lot you can tell what it's a
corolla
it's a toyota corolla
and you're like how many miles he's like
don't worry about it
can i kick the tires nope
is there an engine is there an engine in
it i'm telling you there is i drove it
here
i walked i would go right so you just
need to buy this thing so you finally
get to look under the hood yeah of this
thing what would you see what did we
actually buy when you got in there
you know i i think that
i mean where to go with that question i
could go so many different directions
i think we bought exactly what we needed
and and the challenge
was
that i i didn't anticipate was a double
merger
of companies and cultures
a double merger of companies and
cultures
i did not anticipate the difficulty of
that
um
yeah we went in there we stripped out 17
roll-off dumpsters full of stuff
we gutted the lights and put all leds we
put 75 000 of freon into the system so
we had cooling in there so it wasn't a
sweatshop
like we went through and with machinery
we bought new machinery we stripped
stuff apart we built a fulfillment
center we stripped out the warehouse we
got new controllers custom controllers
we bought new dryers like we i mean we
did everything we do from an
infrastructure but a double merger of
com of companies and culture was the
tricky part that um
the first like pictures you're sending
me
you you're like half laughing and half
crying you're like you're like uh like
back there there's a wash house it's in
there you know there's just
piles of equipment with and it looked
like you know areas of the factory
obviously hadn't been cleaned or used in
decades in decades uh
you know
i remember you you know excited because
you found the floor
in some of the areas like you actually
like got enough stuff out of there so
that you found the floor
uh people were smoking inside the
building choco
cigarettes
i walked through and i'm like i'm
walking i'm walking i'm like
i'm like
there must be some smoke coming in and i
walk by and there's a person smoking a
cigarette i'm talking this is straight
out of the 70s bro like like [__] hasn't
changed since 1970
same type of a culture
same type of a setup
hasn't changed
it looked rough now you're going to tell
everybody to change
the cool thing was you know before we
get to the merging of cultures
uh
that and i've been talking about this uh
a decent amount lately so you know we we
even say that's on front like hey it's
not it's not the it's not what you hang
on the wall you can't just run around
with a bunch of sayings but actually it
kind of does help
and i talked about you know the fact
that david hackworth changed fighter
company or sorry fox company in in korea
to fight her company and he changed the
the hopeless in vietnam off the 439th he
changed the hopeless to the hardcore he
just changed these names changed these
things hey gave them little patches to
wear on their uniforms right
made their salute into hardcore recondos
no [__] slack like he made these
changes like just just made them and
that starts to shift things and you know
out of the gate
you're just like cleaning just just
cleaning this place up right
getting rid of a lot of this junk
getting rid of a lot of these old
machines that weren't that didn't have
any purpose anymore painting things
inc a wage increase across the board for
everybody yeah like out of the gate
making seven dollars and fifty cents an
hour dude yeah making minimum north
carolina wage seven dollars and fifty
cents an hour who can live off of seven
dollars and fifty cents an hour
so the wage increase
the cooling system you talk about i mean
you know like you gotta post that
cooling system again that thing's a
monster oh it's like i don't understand
like yeah the swamp cooler there's
there's like a small pool of water in
there
it's like crazy right but and and what
was the little bet you had with kip like
i'll give you a thousand dollars if you
can get this thing running or something
what was the deal on that kip came down
and he's k you got to remember kim's
been in a lot of factories and
i hope he doesn't mind me sharing this
but he he told me once like he went into
a factory they drove you know an hour
then they drove you know 15 miles down
this dirt road
and then they then they at the corner of
the dirt road there was somebody
carrying he thought it was like bananas
or something out of the forest then they
drove down an elephant trail another
five miles into the middle of a jungle
where people were like carrying out
whatever he didn't know
and there's this building there's this
three-story big brick building with bars
on the windows
and he's like
don't tell me this is a factory and he
goes in
and there's a bunch of girls young young
girls in there sewing
and he's like get me the hell out of
here and what those folks were carrying
out and bare feet was the garments
and of course you know
he's like
i think i think for like kip like he
knows what factories
good factories look like he knows what
infrastructure looks like he knows
what's right and he knows what's wrong
he's seen it all
he walked into the that back room with
jason gaddy and jason yeah jason is he's
like you know kind of got that sales
personality oh my look at this he's like
he got that song cool we got this we got
that he's like this thing it shoots out
it'll it'll cool this whole place down
and kip's like this thing ain't working
jason he's like no it's it's working
it's good to go you just gotta
keep go walks over he's like yeah
there's no way
yeah there's no way this works he's like
no it works and kip's like i'll bet you
a thousand dollars
that this thing doesn't work
come to find out that [__] didn't work
that [__] didn't work
i think i think kit found out like two
weeks ago that uh we we had to dump that
type of cash into it but
stuff stuff like that definitely
important
well all that was happening for me it
was more of how am i to connect with the
people
that have learned
leadership from wall-e
again this dude is living in the 70s 80s
where you protected your own
at whatever cost
how am i going to
untangle
and
re-educate
what our culture is like how we lead how
we treat people
and i remember
the first thing i did was i went up to
the three managers and
they're all looking at me like who is
this guy you know what i mean like and i
i just i said to him i said listen
i said
they're like are you gonna fire us i
said no i'm not gonna fire you you're
gonna fire us and bring your own people
and no well how do we know that
i said
we didn't buy this place because of the
machinery or the building and said we
bought it because of the people i said
that woman over there that's felling
jeans i have never seen anything like it
that one over there i said i've never
seen anything like it i said the skill
here you don't find in america anymore i
said we're here because of you and
nothing else
that's it
and the one there's this one woman and
she's staring at me
staring through me i was actually a
little bit feared for my life and i get
done and she does this little smirk and
she smiles she goes
i like you
and she just walks off and it was like a
lot of those you know keeping those
conversations warm and touch points
it was it was just the beginning we're
in process right now
obviously of trying to continue changing
the culture and it's it's difficult man
i mean obviously you've come down twice
already what did you think when you
first walked in for the first time
i was freaking totally stoked uh but
you know you can tell
again this is something that i get to
see a lot at echelon front and i could
see in the military too you could tell
that the
people had
some level of for lack of a letter a
better word i've said this phrase the
other day uh
post-traumatic leadership disorder right
yeah so
you have
wally who's a survivor who's going to
crush destroy
kick ass to
to to make this work
and that what does that translate to on
the front lines tyrannical leadership
like you're going to shut up and do it
the way i'm telling you that's it that's
the way it is and you could tell that
that's the environment that these folks
now by the time i got down there again
the lights were in the place was clean
so you started to see you i could smell
the the hope right i could start smell
but then you know we'll get into some of
the conversations that we had as we went
forward ashland front showed up there
uh you could start to see okay but i i
when i got in there i actually saw hope
and i saw people looking at me and
as i started talking to people you see
that there's hope there and they were
ready for that transition what's
so
we'll get to that in the meantime
the other monster yeah he's out there i
think people really got to understand
there's
like there's two monsters we're walking
through the factory getting phone calls
about this 100 and we're doing this
other thing we're getting phone calls
about these these deals it's just it's a
lot it's a lot it's
the other monster now he's freaking
opera the other monster's hungry
we you know
one of the main things that we wanted to
get done was make a ready to drink mulk
that people could go into a store
and say hey i need protein right now i
need to fill myself up i need some
nutrition
i want it to be healthy
we we need ready to drink molk
we've had great
success and supreme demand for the
powdered milk i mean it's the best stuff
going so but people sometimes you don't
have time to you don't have a shape cup
all this thing so we need to make a
ready to drink mulk
and
that was a cha cha cha challenge yeah
it's a challenge to make the right
formula a challenge to make the formula
as healthy as it can possibly be as
efficacious as it could possibly be and
you gotta counter that with making it
taste as good as you can possibly make
it so people wanna drink it so it tastes
good
and so we have all those just to
formulate the thing
and once you formulate it guess what you
gotta do
you gotta actually make it
so how's this going down yeah i mean it
it's funny and listening to you talking
it's all about
this whole thing that we're we're doing
not trying to do we're we're doing it
we're executing something it
it's all around
people and community
like it takes people it takes knowledge
it takes equipment it takes community
like it it's the same damn thing we're
trying to make stuff you know we're
trying to not lose who we are
because if if we do
i mean i don't even i don't even want to
guess at what happens for our kids
generation
and honestly i was saying to somebody
the other day
it's on it's on us right now it's on the
it's on the gen xers i mean us three at
this table it's on us we're the next
leaders of this nation
we're the businessmen and women of this
nation we're gonna drive the direction
we're gonna drive a divide or we're
gonna we're gonna try to unify you know
in in
i was explaining these market dynamics
um actually to kip in in the team
that
like what are we trying to do
and i'll try not to get off on a tangent
here but
you have the greatest generation
the greatest generation
were responsible for turning on the war
machine of world war ii america's war
machine which was america's factories we
had the capabilities we had the
knowledge we knew how to build tooling
if we didn't have it we knew how to make
machines from scratch from ore
from iron ore we would we would freaking
heat and cast and mold and pound that
[__] into shape until it turned into a
tank or a truck whatever we needed
and we've we've truly have lost that and
it's been crushing the middle class you
know and and this is all about trying to
trying to give the middle class what
makes america great which is real
opportunity
because without it who who are we
you know this
i guess it's just a 250 year
seizure you know and
we're trying to do something about it so
i guess i guess my point is is um
we've kept this singleness of purpose
across the board
on origin and on jocko fuel and although
one serves the things you wear and need
and use in life the other one actually
serves you know the things you need for
nutrition and you need to you need to
consume this stuff
i was in europe a couple weeks ago
there's there's foods that are illegal
that are made here you can't buy [__] in
europe
you know like stuff that comes in boxes
that you know has it's at the end of it
and cheese at the beginning you're like
that type of stuff
that you want to consume by the handfuls
but you know like we're like the things
that
these big conglomerates are able to make
you know like they're just not good for
you and and we're trying to make
something that's good for you
um
so this this market dynamic
of this
this world war ii generation that is all
but gone that past the stories on to us
gen xers these were the future leaders
our kids
have never i don't want to say have
never had any authentic experiences but
most of their experiences come through a
device
likes follows
friends through this device
they didn't hear the stories from the
greatest generation directly so they
they lie with us
they've never really experienced
anything authentic they've never walked
into a factory
and so you have this void of
i don't want to use the word
authenticity but you have this void of
reality
because everything is behind a screen
you can't
see it truly you can't smell it really
you can't feel it
and ultimately you don't know who made
it
in
in there's something missing the thing
that's missing is what what they fought
for right it's what the greatest
generation fought for it's what they
went to war for to protect the things we
had and then we sell those things to the
lowest bidder
that's what we did we sold it to the
but we let it happen
and
origin and jocko fuel like the things
we're doing it sits in the middle of
this triangle where our our kids are
gonna
they're gonna experience something
authentic for the first time they're
gonna walk into a factory and go whoa
whoa
what is this
and they're gonna pick up a boot and
smell the leather
so we're going to leverage this
technology they're used to to tell a
different story to write a different
script to change the narrative and
that's the idea here and use
in use in in
and not romanticize about the greatest
generation but honor them through what
we're doing
and that's that's the ultimate goal
like when you look at this immersion
camp we're here in this immersion camp
right now
you got 350 people here and we're
walking through the factory yesterday in
in for the first time 70 of the people
here have never been here they've never
been to the factory
the looks on their faces and the
questions they're asking i mean we spent
four hours walking through the factories
and they're just like
wow
and i know you've had a ton of people
come up to you and i've had a ton of
people come up to me but
we're not selling them anything
we're showing them a way to do something
you know they manifest
what
their belief in what we're doing and
their alignment with what they're we're
doing they manifest that by purchasing a
oh do you repair jeans or boots or
grabbing a mock or go but it's they're
living into the same thing
we're leaning into
and
and i think that that's what makes it so
not not not powerful it's what makes it
so important
it's why wally
sold us that the factory
that's what he saw he saw a generation
that actually could do what he did
because he didn't believe he didn't
believe it was going to happen he did he
thinks he thought we were too soft soft
and weak
so um
there's a there's a mindset there's
there's a
an
error there's a there's a frequency that
we're all working on to try to make this
[__] happen
and it and it all it all is living
as ideas in
and and wanting to be executed but
sometimes
recklessly and we're trying to organize
that so that it's
it's executed more refined i guess you
could say
whether it's with the genes
whether it's with trying to make mulk
rtds
and it sounds silly a little bit for me
to say it like that but
it's not because that [__] is hard to
make there's five people in america who
can make it that we know of we're
looking for more hey listen if you can
make this monk rtd for us in america
please let us know
uh because it it's been difficult
what we wanted to do to keep it clean
you know the the way we needed to
package it aha
how we wanted to keep it actually good
for you and healthy for you there's
actually not a lot of people who can do
that and the people who can
the people who can
are held back
by the big brands who have the market
share and the control
and
we're trying to come in
and trying to take some of that market
share and take some of that line time
and those big brands
pay them off
to not let us in or anyone like us in
they're not going to let us in
they ain't letting us on the line
they're not giving up an ounce of market
share to us
good thing we're fighters
you know what i mean like
a little bit of is a little bit arrogant
at times
uh but uncompromising so
you know we're we're in we're in that
process right now i mean we can't make
what we need to make for the supply we
can make a certain amount
you know like we have the product we've
had it our first manufacturer who
committed to us then dropped us i'm sure
they got a a side deal meal some type of
check cut to keep us out of the line
just shut keep the line shut yeah just
don't make anything they're paying them
not they either are going to make them
or they're not going to make anybody
else right and these companies are
getting paid off to do that make
anything not to make anything
uh
just to go back to your your tangent
about making things and what it's like
to see that i i think there's a a
certain human instinct that we have that
a certain dopamine reward that we get
for creating things right otherwise how
would we be here
how would we as human beings have lasted
if we didn't get a little dopamine hit
from building a freaking
a roof over our head with sticks
or put rocks into a circle and make a
fire if you didn't get some kind of
dopamine hit from that
we wouldn't be we wouldn't exist a human
being so i think we all have that and if
anybody's you know ever if you've ever
created anything if you've ever made
anything you get that little dopamine
hit oh yeah if you've you know when you
were a little kid and you made a tree
fort you enjoyed that as you get older
you remodel the kitchen if you did that
you hung drywall at the end of the day
you looked up you got a dopamine hit i
remember once i was building a retaining
wall in my backyard i was in the navy i
was probably but i was you know i was
like probably
i guess i was
16 17 years in the navy and i had taken
you know a three-day weekend so i could
build a retaining wall i'm out there
laying bricks laying block
and i remember i got done and
i just came in i said you know hey babe
i think when i retire i'm gonna become a
mason
you know like
no one's bothering me
i'm listening to some music the block
don't talk it's the block isn't gonna
die it's not even gonna get injured
it's and and look at what i did today
you know like it's a good feeling that
dopamine hit is a real thing and
unfortunately
the dopamine hit is subsidized by you
know clicking you know deliver this to
my house and
it seems like they don't even want you
to understand where this stuff came from
they just want you to get the dopamine
hit of hitting add to cart yes right
they don't want you to know what it
feels like to make this stuff
and you rip that out that's why you see
uh you know for years now for for kids
it's been oh you know what you need to
do is you need to go to college
and learn
you know you need to computer science
computer science or liberal arts
but you're not going to go to a
technical school we don't want you to go
to a technical we don't want you to be
an electrician we don't want you to be a
plumber we don't want you to be a mason
we don't want you to be a carpenter we
don't want you to know how to work a
loom we want but we want you to buy this
stuff
so there's like a capitalization of of
dopamine
and they make it easier and you know
even like you know you throughout
computer science actually people that do
good computer science and computer
engineering
they get dopamine hits because they're
building something yeah and it's
something that they can make i mean echo
you i can tell you get dopamine when you
make a video and it's good you even make
a part of a video sometime and you're
like hey i built this
and there's a certain amount of
satisfaction and like that's a certain
amount that's something i don't
understand i can't make anything on a
computer as you know right
yes
but
i know that you get it from there and i
get to go straight to the source on that
so
this is what happens
i think you know it's like uh look i'm
not gonna sit here and say it's a
conspiracy theory or conspiracy that you
know the big corporations don't want
people to to to make things on their own
but that's just the way it's turned out
the way it's turned out is is
if you want to make for instance a ready
to drink protein
they don't want you to know how good
that feels to deliver that product and
have people have a healthy choice when
they go out they don't want you to feel
that
because if you feel that other people
might feel it and if other people might
feel it all of a sudden we got a problem
on our hands
dude 100
it's like freaking soylent green yeah
the way this [__] works remember that
movie yeah they're lining up to eat the
wafers man yep everybody's lining up to
eat the wafers and we're like the
insurgency right saying hey
join us there's a better way hey
here's the truth
we got to have truth yeah
you got to have truth so
so we
so through great effort we eventually we
we find a manufacturer in canada
yeah that's seven hours away yeah our
neighbors and our neighbor
god bless
uh and they're up there and they're you
know not they're not willing to sit back
and
shut down their line for money right
they want to have things made
good on them so the malt comes here's
another you know it's just another
the flavors on the go right so we got
discipline go where when the first one
come out a year ago
two years ago was it two years the new
the new adjuster no when's their very
first discipline go who can remember so
colors we have one flavor it comes out
it's based on my taste buds which is a
bad idea
i don't drink
sugar i don't eat sugar or let me
rephrase it i don't drink a lot i
haven't drink in a coca-cola in decades
right
so the very first jaco discipline go
that i had
which had a little bit of monk fruit in
it it to me it tasted like freaking you
know candy cane almost right i'm like oh
hell yeah this is sweet hell yeah
and that's sort of the the baseline that
we used in the beginning for the drink
and the bottom line is it was uh
to use echo's term and echoes correct
he's like you're not normal meaning
jocko you're not normal and he's right
my taste buds are not normal and
so we ended up as we developed the
flavors
for the discipline go
look we made the best possible drink the
efforts that we went through to make it
how we made it
to make it as clean and make it as
natural to hold off on making it for
seven or eight months so we could
actually pasteurize instead of just hey
you know what why don't you just throw
some chemicals in there
just throw them in there it'll be okay
no no we're not gonna do that we're
gonna pasteurize it
what about hey monk fruit's kind of
expensive
we can throw some you know some of the
aspartame we can do that hey no one will
really know yes we know i know
we're not doing it we're going to hold
the line so we make
well you should just dump a bunch of
caffeine that way people will feel it
yeah then they're going to crash too and
it's not going to it's freaking bad for
them we're not doing it
so we end up making an outstanding drink
in terms of performance
but taste
not the best
definitely needed to get better
so we had to attack that issue man i got
really happy i got really used to the
taste by the way yeah so did i and i was
like i like it's like
if you drink coffee for the first time
yeah of course this is a thousand times
better than coffee dude i i don't drink
coffee i did a spurt of five years i
drank coffee in the beginning of
starting origin i don't drink coffee
though and i never drank before because
i think coffee is disgusting i think it
tastes bad i think it tastes really good
with a lot of sugar cubes and some milk
and maybe throw some whipped cream in
there but that's not really coffee you
know what i'm saying so
um i i really did like and i i actually
drank mango as i drank a mango every day
you know one can of mango every morning
that's that was my
best part of waking up was mango in my
mouth you know what i'm saying so and i
love the the iced tea lemonade yeah and
that's what so the old flavors were like
this
usually
people had one that they really liked
yes i had one and they had two that they
thought were okay yep and they had three
that they literally didn't like at all
which is not good no right
so we knew we had to
redo these flavors and we
what we ended up having to do is say hey
you know what
we need help
we've reached the maximum capacity of
our capabilities
and reached out to professionals that
actually
formulate flavors and can help and
helped us put together and reformulate
the flavors on all the drinks and man
what a freaking difference yeah i mean
the new flavors
all of them this is what it's like now
you'll have three that you love
and you'll have four that you absolutely
love almost as much
but i i actually
drink every single flavor they're all
delicious now they're all delicious now
so
that was huge
but we had to destroy some flavors this
is what's crazy right it's not like you
snap your fingers and now you have new
flavors no this is a massive investment
financially to to bring these new
flavors around the testing the hey no
this one sucks no i wanted a little
sweeter less lime
you know more cherry all these things
going back and forth
hanging to get all these things
formulated and then once you get them
formulated well that now you've gotta
adjust
all the cans that you've made and you've
got some cans that are sitting around
that now what are we gonna do with these
so this was a
a a massive effort a massive effort
um but
you know what i i remember the uh
i don't want to say the the dictum that
i put out like the the commander's
intent that i put out was
we need to win on taste
like we're look we're winning on
everything else everything else we've
we've got everyone else crushed we've
got them no one can touch us
we need to win on taste if it doesn't
taste good we can it doesn't matter and
we we did it we did it now we're winning
on taste so now we're winning we got the
the best tasting we got the most
efficient and now
that means
that right there
was the production of all the weapons
right there that was the production of
all the weapons and all the battleships
and all the aircraft carriers and all
the airplanes and all the howitzers in
world war ii we made this and now
they're out now it's now it's time to
take them into battle and this is this
is
so such a fascinating world
this battle that goes on
in the business world and i never knew
about it i mean i certainly didn't know
know about this three four years ago
what's going on when you go into stores
how that how that functions so you go
into a store you go into a convenience
store
and you see
a you know 20 different energy drinks in
the in the in the cooler in the
refrigerator
and
those energy drinks to get into that
cooler
had to fight to get in there
and what that means is they in many
cases had to pay to get in there they
had to pay millions of dollars to get
that shelf space
and
each one of those different brands that
you're looking at in there some of them
have paid more some of them had paid
have paid less
if you happen to have a a drink that
just performs great guess what they
don't have to pay a bunch to get in
there
if you have something like jocko fuel
where we do perform
we haven't paid to get in there
yes we're getting by on actual
performance
and that's good
because the amount of money that gets
thrown around in these deals we're
talking about billion dollar companies
multi-billion dollar companies so you
got that war going on
so that every
every space
in that shelf
is fought for
and you know what when you go in and you
support you go in and you buy a jocko go
from a convenience store or you go into
a grocery store and you buy it you are
you're you're calling for reinforcements
you're you're opening up the gates for
reinforcements to get in there so when
you do that thank you for doing that
not only are you supporting yourself
you're supporting
the the company which means you're
supporting america so thank you for
doing that so you got that war going on
one front the other war is this virtual
war that you've got going on which is
insane
so whether it's
search words
on google
or searching in amazon you see this
again well they don't they don't call it
conquest for no reason there's there's
conquest somebody
this is a war term this is where i
started to understand what was happening
on amazon
uh you know years ago i'm at echelon
front and i like certain kinds of pens
as stupid as that might sound you know
i'm kind of a particular guy uncle
charles yes i like things a certain way
right there's one right there
i like certain kind of pens i like
certain types of pencils i like certain
types of paper so you know one time i
was like ordering one of my pens this is
an
and ain't no freaking mont blanc dude
over here i'm not rolling on a 200 pen
or whatever i like pens that cost 2.59
so i would order one pen
for 2.59 and amazon says yep
it'll be there tomorrow at your
house so i'm thinking to myself
that's crazy i don't know how they're
doing this it had to it's got to cost
them
how much does it cost for them to
deliver this thing to my house a lot
more than two dollars more than 2 000
and what's the what you know what's
their profit margin on two dollars on in
59 cents or 239 cents
what is it 20 cents
it cost them two dollars to get this
thing to my door at an absolute minimum
so how in god's name are they making
money how is that happening
well
when i searched
pen
there's 12 pens that come up and each
one of them is paying to pop up on my
computer screen and lure me into buying
them
and that's happening billions of times a
day
so
there's this virtual war going on inside
of amazon
and it was crazy
as we put our products on amazon
that if you searched
jocko protein
before we understood the battlefield
you'd search jocko protein and there
would be nine proteins come up none of
which would be jocko fuel or you'd
search krill oil
and seven krill oils would pop up and
none of them would be jocko fuel and
this confused me for about four hours
and then i said hey what in god's name
is going on and guess what people are
paying and the word you just use is
conquest explain that explain how that
works i mean we we like to do it every
now and then
i mean you gotta fight fight fire with
fire a little bit but
learning the landscape first of all in
in obviously getting smart people
involved was key to our hiring process
of getting i call it expanding the brain
trust you know what i mean
um basically it works like this
you find smarter people
and you
algorithmically bid
so if you have ai that's even better
against your competitors and then you
conquest them by using their name so
regardless if they're searching for you
or searching or
using their brand name you're coming up
and that's that's the war you know
that's a war online yeah 100 and it's no
different than in the stores except that
you know the companies with and we're in
this war right now we're in this war in
the store right now
we we have
a company that
is offering millions of dollars for
shelf space
which we need
we can't fight that battle
so we're working on some other
techniques which we won't share to to
flank it and stay where we need to stay
ultimately and continue driving velocity
to to prove out what we're doing not
just to the store but to the consumer
also so yeah there's a lot of moving
parts there yeah and the best thing
the best so so here's a uh
people talking i've written a bunch of
books right yeah and people like oh you
know what's up what's the key to like
making new york times bestseller what's
the key to having a best-selling book
and the key is
write a good book
that's the actual key so the best thing
that we can do is what we've done make
the best possible product make it taste
as good as it possibly can and that is
why we're in there in the first place we
wouldn't we didn't have we don't have
the the the
the firepower
to break through the door what gets us
into these all these different places is
the high demand signal so thank you all
out there right now tuning in listening
going hell yeah
clear the show yes clearly the show
you're out there clearing yourselves
that's that's literally what made this
happen that's what that's what keeps us
going the the product the effect the
effectiveness of the product the taste
the product that's the number one weapon
to to make this happen
but and that's what we have to use
is because that's what we have we don't
have billions of dollars we can't throw
tens of millions of dollars
at a store to say can you give us a few
more can you get rid of our competitor
because that's what happens and look
this is business
i get it and they can win
i get that too you can understand wally
a little bit yeah you can understand
wally's mindset with his that protective
mindset we're we're doing the same thing
you know like we're going to buy line
time we're going we're going to go by
we're in the process of it we just
secured 20 25 line time for mok rtds
2025 should ain't even set up yet and
we're going to own that why because you
got to be a savage about it you got to
protect what you're building
so
it is it helps me understand his mindset
by our mindset with how we're building
this yep
and you have to like you just said you
have to be a savage because if you're
not
you have to be a predator you have to go
you have to be a predator because
otherwise you'll get eaten you you just
look like prey and in these big
companies it's you know it's us down
here
you know scrapping
and they can just you know they can
throw money at stuff and you know what
and like i said they can win that's the
way that's the way things work
but
we also have advantages
and that's what we're going to utilize
you know this is how this is how
insurgencies work how do small little
gorillas running around in the jungle
defeat giant imperialist countries it's
an insurgency there's belief there's
there's belief in what's happening
there's unity in the people that's what
we have we have people that believe we
have unity and that's our strength and
that's how we're gonna win
on that battlefield
now
meanwhile
again while all this is going on which
is a daily fight a daily fight
uh meanwhile we got this double merger
going on it's actually more of like
a triple we have a triple merger going
on
because now in north carolina what we
end up with is we have factory one
that we bought
now we have and it's not like factory
one was bought and now everyone we've
been there for long enough now
everyone's completely transitioned into
everyone understands what we're doing
and everyone's on board with the way our
leadership works no that that's still
going on
boom now we buy another factory
and now we have the origin culture
factory one and factory two all these
cultures merging in
one
shot
at one time what's that looking like
well don't don't forget and and maybe
you wanted to save this but while all
this is going on
we have this kind of aggressive and bold
idea of building an american-made hunt
line
in this factory that we're going to
double merge together
so
i don't know if that's crazy it is it's
a it's a little bit crazy
what we're trying to do is
you you're not right in the head
i think i think that's what makes it all
work is
other other other companies
they're not willing to
pull out all stops
it's it's uh
it's it's not it's not normal
it's necessary though like you said
so
double merger
trying to build culture at the same time
developing textiles developing camo
trying to get this wash house up so we
can wash jeans developing new fits
hiring a product team getting the
logistics figure out building out a new
direct-to-consumer warehouse training
people on that hiring
operators like hiring new c-level
executives having to have board meetings
expanding the finance team
it's it's a lot it's a big ass wave man
i'm like i'm just like and from in and
honestly from like
my perspective these monsters went from
like komodo dragons to godzilla yeah
yeah 100 that's freaking weird bro so
somebody said to me recently man
you're hard work guys i
actually i will not outwork you
i will out adhd you
that's it
i i got adhd for days man like i can
bounce around but it gets to a point
where like
you got to organize the chaos
you know in in
and you can use your ada i can use it as
a super power
but
stepping back in in like hey letting
people start to organize this chaos
you know into a machine it's like you
got all these parts and pieces but like
putting them together dumping some oil
putting the grease on and tuning it in
and letting it run it's kind of where
we're at right now
is
it's together
but it's squeaking man it's squeaking
and and we know what needs to be done
but the biggest part of that is culture
and honestly it's on both it's on both
sides of this two-headed monster you
know is keeping that consistent culture
driving it down
i believe the most important thing you
can have in business is culture you know
i think if you have good culture you can
do anything and we've seen that in a
positive light and war and we've seen
that in a very negative light and more
if you can get buy-in from the people
and you can and you can
create a mindset a mission and a mindset
around that mission that people are
willing to execute against and go to war
for
you can truly do anything you truly can
do anything
i've always believed that as a kid when
they said you can be anything you want
to be you can do anything in life i
actually believed that [__] out maybe i
was naive but i believed it you know
what i'm saying and and i still and i
still do believe it so
you know like
i remember calling you up and being like
and we don't need to share it here but
like hey jocko we've got some problems
we've got some problems trying to merge
this thing together
i shared some of those concerns with you
of that mindset from the 70s and 80s
that was really not gonna work and
really not okay
um
and at that and at that point obviously
you were like yeah i'm freaking in
you know and getting the teams together
feeding them having a meal and then like
showing them and going to town on like
who we are and what we're all about and
what culture means and what leadership
means and how to lead and how to
communicate
like
it's it's not like and i know you've
been down twice now for the whole team
then for the management team i believe
it's going to take
like
some people going to musters some of
some of you coming back to the factory
you know like it's going to take this
constant alignment over the course of 24
months
that's how long the double merger is
going to take yeah yeah yeah and that's
pretty standard right um i don't know
man you tell me i mean this is all the
time i don't know i am telling you yeah
i'm with the trenches you you can't it's
not an inoculation you don't go to one
no jocko talk about extreme ownership
okay cool now i get it now we can move
on it doesn't work like that um
but what's what is beautiful is you can
see you can see progress i mean
uh
like you know you mentioned about
jason's project progress
as his mind opened up as he started to
understand
other ways to lead and get out of just a
survival mode which is a good thing but
it's not as good as a as a build and
thrive and and take over mode right
that's that's the thing and just like
like a really simple thing
when i talk to the team in north
carolina
just explaining to them
that
leadership wanted their feedback
leadership wanted to know if there was
something on the line that didn't make
sense i remember asking you know
something along the lines of like who do
you who here thinks jason knows how to
hem that thing better than the person
that sits on the machine all day
everyone's like of course the person on
the machine so if jason's telling you to
do something the wrong way
doesn't it make sense that you say hey
this doesn't work or here's a better way
to do it yes and like the the light on
their faces
was
it was a beautiful thing to see because
you can see that they're they do have
ideas in there they have better ways of
doing things and they can definitely
help us improve and they will help us
and they are helping us improve
and of course you still have to power
through the fact that they've been
underneath leadership that didn't do
that for a long time it was like hey
you're going to do what we say we don't
want to hear from you so this is a this
is where things start to change and
jason says he's getting that feedback
that he needs so no there's not going to
be an overnight transition that's not
going to happen but what's beautiful is
that transition is already happening you
already see the improvement you already
see the attitude the the difference
between when i went down there the first
time and i went down there the second
time a couple months apart took
radically different radically different
situation you could see the difference
on the floor you can see the people
smiling you can see them looking wanting
to show me something want me to look at
this oh come and look that's what you
see and and and that's just like that's
where we're going that's the culture
starting to grow and the other thing is
you can't impose culture right you can't
say okay here's the new culture a
through z this is what no it it has to
like all go into the pot and we have to
cook it together and they have to
realize and there's going to be some
things that they're going to give to us
and so that's the beautiful thing is to
watch this thing uh
watch that unfold
hunt line
so first of all
you being in maine beating and being in
the in the woods of maine hunting is a
way of life up here so way of life you
know i know you're i know joe your
father-in-law he's a hunter you're a
hunter i remember your son out running
trap lines like this is the way of life
in maine
so for hunting for you is like oh yeah
this is a no-brainer
yeah i mean it total a total no-brainer
you know and in that community's also
you know they're also patriots and they
heavily believe in the land
they heavily believe in america
and the fact that you know
they don't have an option
that is made
here
with textiles that were made here like
the fact that there's no option anymore
you know we actually in my last company
in the early 2000s we actually
manufactured i mean we uh did marketing
for this company it's called beagleware
and they did a wool and i
still wear that hunting and i don't hunt
a lot anymore um
because you know i'm trying to feed two
monsters seven days a week
uh but uh but i remember that's what i
still wear hunting right now as i wear
this wool beagle wear which has a dwr on
it freaking stuff is phenomenal that for
me was always like the pinnacle of like
hunting gear made in america made in
vermont
to bring this to fruition and to bring a
product at the level we've brought it to
on an american supply chain
is
it's it's a it's a little bit of a
miracle
that we did it and i'll tell you what if
we didn't have the team we did
in the vision we had and honestly with
with kip involved in in in his knowledge
base of building under armour and
in him keeping us
away from making tuition payments i
don't think it would happen without kim
yeah i i don't well
yeah
it would not have not even don't think
we would not have done it without kim
exactly so
big a big advocate there and and really
driving how things should go in and it's
been for me it's been a year of learning
yeah i'm kind of
you know directing both organizations
both monsters
but
you know he's he's been there like
really calling out
really calling it out in the kip way you
know what i mean which is
a little bit savage at times i've just
kind of kept my mouth shut and executed
so i've been i feel like
a little bit i've been just
working from hit for him on the hunt
line you know i'm like working i'm
working for him and i'm totally okay
with that
like that dude is he he's been driving
this thing
but
understanding his thought process
of how to build product and i'm not just
talking about hunt but the thought
process of how to build great product
with innovation how to think about
supply chains and logistics how to
communicate with partners you know how
to build relationships that are lasting
how to talk to
consumers
it's
i i feel like i've had a
like a
college education over the past year
it's been freaking phenomenal you've got
a hell of a lot more than a college
education dude because kip has
this experience that you just you're
just not you can't you could never
you can't learn what kip knows yeah you
can't you can't learn that from a book
or from a from a seminar or from a
college course like ever you cannot
learn what he knows
you have to have lived it
and yes and i i actually told him last
week on the phone i was like man you got
to get a hold of jocko and you gotta
cause
i've been trying to push him to like
write a book under the armor like and to
tell the stories and i'm like jocko can
publish that [__] dude like
dude call him and talk to him about it
but also like start a youtube channel
and kip's a bit of a savage you know
what i mean the way he talks he's just
different he's different
um
but uh but a super positive influence on
what we're doing as an organization
building this hunt line wasn't easy the
alpha bravo trolley layering system the
way we're using wool
you know which is really core to who we
are is this natural fiber
um in our nano wool and our base layer
and our stealth wool and mid layer just
fyi yeah it's not your
dad's wool and it's not your granddad's
wall no it's it's a totally different
kind of wool fine micron american merino
wool
it doesn't it doesn't feel like well i
don't know echo how are you 44 yes sir
oh yeah well i was going to ask you a
question about wool and i remembered
you're from hawaii that's true
you didn't wear
anything wool growing up ever
no
all right you know we didn't have our
our wool available yet for me to test
and i i had to go to europe a few weeks
ago and we were going to go actually
then we went to scotland
and so i bought a smartwool you know
that brand i bought some socks dude yeah
i wear those socks during like all
temperatures yeah i didn't i want i
didn't get it what like merino wool did
to regulate your body
i my feet don't sweat in it
it doesn't make sense yeah it doesn't
make sense how this natural fiber that's
so old
can be used still very in innovatively
you know what i mean like it's a it's an
incredible fiber so you know we we
we
leveraged this fine micron merino wool
we blended it we produced these
incredible textiles we gleaned some of
the knowledge from spec ops you know
that hasn't been commercialized yet
um and we put this incredible line
together freaking printed
roller printed sublimated acid printed
like badass textiles that were cutting
and sewing and turning into freaking
america
america's first truly american-made hunt
line without compromise on the origin
factory blockchain there is not another
company doing that
i'll give you what anybody says there's
not another company yeah there's there's
some there's when you mention the spec
ops the military base of this year
there's something called
uh
berry compliant so barry was a
representative or something and he
created a law where where
military
had the deal the defense department had
to purchase stuff that was american-made
and it includes a whole bunch of
different things
you know metal made products but
textiles and clothing is one of them
and it's it's probably the biggest
category
and
and so these things exist if it wasn't
for that honestly this stuff probably
wouldn't exist and we would have had to
build a freaking me because the mil
there wouldn't even be mills here we
would have probably had to build a mill
and make the stuff ourselves but luckily
that did exist so thank you
representative barry wherever you may be
for putting that law into place because
it kept some level of manufacturing here
so we were able to get a hold of that
material and and utilize that material
that's that's outstanding material
uh it's available
but it's hard and and what where they
get away with some of this stuff is like
the the berry loss of it says some
exceptions
are due to unavailability cost or
manufacturing efficiencies of us-based
products so there's a claim that people
can make well you know we can't quite
make that type of zipper so we're gonna
get it overseas but we can't make this
type of nylon so we're gonna get it
overseas or it's gonna cost too much
it's literally it costs too much so
we're going to do it overseas so there's
ways that people get around it and they
can still call it very compliant
we're better than barry compliant better
than barry that's and that's what we
externally like on our website we
we have to save for the consumer
something so we say very compliant
internally we're better than barry
let me give you an example
you know
there's a company in maine that makes
boots
in
their uppers
the full upper of the boot which is the
boot without the sole
comes in from mexico
and they call they bottom it that's what
it's called bottoming so
they put a sole on it and they put laces
in it
and it's american-made
that technically is is very compliant
right right
internally we are better than barry
that's a big deal to say that hey man
you know when you buy a pair of boots
that soul
that came actually from massachusetts
from vibram they injected it there that
leather came from wisconsin those
eyelids came from here like it all you
know like that poron midsole on the
jeans that cotton was grown by it texas
that rivet yeah exactly that's it you
know what so better than berry is is
what we stand by internally and that's
the only way that we continue
building the limited supply chains and
and helping
everybody
everybody that touches any part of that
product any component that's how we
rebuild the communities that's how we
build the supply chain that's how we
build america yeah and this
you know you mentioned that
hunters are are
the
probably the most patriotic people in
this country as a whole right and that's
one of the things that you know in
talking to camp haynes right i mean just
a a
world-renowned hunter um
you know he
was looking
to
looking for what he's gonna wear when he
hunts he he needed someone to come on
board with him he needed someone to
support him in his efforts and he could
he could go with any company in the
world i mean he's he's the you know
one of the best if not the best
certainly the most popular of of hunters
and
you know when and luckily of course he
he hunts with kip right yeah he hunts
with kip and they're great friends
and so that's awesome
but still
like
he's a guy that's got you know a family
to support the whole nine yards so it's
not just about oh well this is my buddy
so we're going
man what in when i talked to cam
you know when i talked to cam
what i talked to him about was
was we're doing this in america you know
and he's got a son that's in the rangers
i mean this you know he's a patriotic
hard-working american he's a he's a he's
a blue-collar guy that's worked his ass
off and he knows what that means he
knows what it's like he knows what it
means to supply jobs to other americans
and you know from my perspective and
then look it was also hey you're going
to be have a huge influence over what we
make and how we make it this is going to
be designed it's gonna have your
blessing and it has cam's blessing you
know what what else do we want right
exactly so but it was awesome to be able
to
get cam involved to bring cam on as an
owner yep
because the reason is look he he's not
gonna compromise
on performance it's not happening i mean
look at this dude he's running he's runs
a marathon every day right there's no
compromise on performance with camp so
he's not going to compromise there and
he's not going to compromise on his
patriotism on his love for this country
and you know i i mean
i talked about it with him i'm like hey
when we when we buy stuff from other
countries we're putting money into the
pockets of our adversaries yes
and that's a horrible thing
and that's just this is the way it is
man that's just the way it is and
there's no two ways about that
this that's what we this is an economic
war and they the that that claim
that's not just rhetoric like oh there's
an economic war but no no this is an
actual economic war
and our adversaries are fighting and
sometimes you know even if you look at
at china's past and what
what their theories of war are what sun
tzu said about war they want to fight
without
their opponent knowing that there's a
war going on that's what they want
so of course they don't make a big deal
out of it
but that's what's happening
and and so it was awesome to have cam
come on board to uh a company that
didn't even exist
you know it didn't even exist
but for him to know you know what
this is the right thing to do
and
so thanks to cam and and for coming on
board and then helping with the design
has been freaking awesome and it's been
cool he's already out there hunting
right now by the way he's out there
getting after it there's already blood
on the raptor camo at this time
so
so that's freaking legit
uh but
not an easy thing to get done man holy
crap no man it was um
i'd never seen roller printing before we
didn't know if the wool would hold you
know like this this stealth wall that we
gleaned from the special special forces
we we tweaked it you know so we we took
what they were using for this glove and
we tweaked it for our liking uh with the
with the blend that we wanted
and then
it's like scorched under 1000 degree
heat in it in it and it scorches the
outside and gives it almost a shell a
little bit of a shell type of feel and
we're like cool all that's cool can we
print it
you know like we don't have no idea but
you have to like run
a sizeable amount of the product which
is not cheap at 50 bucks a yard right
you got to run
a bunch of it to see if you can print it
so you're taking all these little risks
you know in in it it really is is what
it's taking to do all this is you're
just taking risks what's the worst that
can happen you lose some money
okay
what's more important loser losing money
or rebuilding this thing so we take the
risks right but seeing for the first
time
that like stealth will go through that
roller printer and come off the other
side
i was like
bro
i i mean i had no words like i looked at
kip he looked at me you know he's like
are you kidding me man look at this [__]
i'm like yeah bro like this is it it was
at that point i i was a believer
you know i was a believer like we
actually can build
a
innovative
high-performing
hunt line in america because there's
some there's some good technical stuff
out there you know there is and um
we still got it i i guess that's what i
would say like we still got it
and it launched what's what's today the
25th yeah it launched it
so it launched pre-order for pre-order
because today yeah and that's be it's
pre-order now because what we made is
sold well yeah it's because we're uh
we're making the stuff right now and
we're still weaving some of the textiles
for some of the line
and you know we're literally making it
it's not like all pre-made it didn't
come over in a freaking container and we
didn't just bring it into a warehouse
and ship it out we're freaking making
the [__] so
if people want it and they want to you
know help
and wear something on american land
that's american-made
put the pre-order in yeah well the other
thing that's that that we were talking
about earlier you were explaining to me
is
we have a limited amount of fabric we
have limited amount of time we have
limited amount of capacity to actually
make this stuff so
if you are out there
and you need
the
the woodland cami
instead of the highland cami we we need
to know that now so we can make it for
you and if you need a size whatever xl
and your wife needs a size medium
we need to know that so we can make the
right thing
so
that's why the pre-order is important on
this stuff so we can make the right
amount of stuff and get it out to y'all
um
what else man
i mean i know
that's kind of like the broad strokes of
the last year what about camp this year
how was camp how's camp echo charles
you've been quiet how's camp good camp
yeah yeah one more a lot more people but
more mellow yeah you've been chilling
man i've been i've been watching you out
of the corner of my this has been a good
conversation yeah
over here just cruising yep it's true
echo and i are matching right now we're
wearing your blue springs
new favorite by the way yeah it's nice
good it's a good look jiu jitsu is
getting more popular dude it's exploding
people love jiu jitsu
are you concerned so we got galvao
versus gordon ryan coming up yeah
um
here's my concern it's going to be hype
right it's going to be hype
one of my concerns like they're saying
there's going to be 20 000 people live
are you going to the 80s it doesn't look
like it because i'll be in the mountains
hunting in rapid camera in raptor
campbell
uh
and it's on sunday too so i actually i
can confirm right now i will not be
there unfortunately
um
here's my concern about this
uh
jiu-jitsu in that match well jiu-jitsu
for
can be boring to watch in certain
situations there are there are there's a
what percentage chances this is a boring
match echo charles
i don't think it'll be boring okay so
you don't think you think it's a 100
exciting match i think the chance of
being exciting is like
85 to 90 okay so okay how many reverse
you think it's
i think it's i think it's gonna be
lackluster i think andre is gonna play
anti-jiu-jitsu and and try to hit like
when the points start a double leg with
three minutes left yes that's what i
think's gonna happen
okay is that the what's the rule set acc
it's 20 minutes super fight in 80 10
minutes no points right 10 minutes
points
10 minute overtime 10 minute overtime so
it could be a total of 40 minutes and
there's
so that's that's the rule set i'm pretty
sure yeah um
i think if i think if gordon doesn't uh
you know how he like calls out his
submissions or whatever if he just goes
in there to win i think it could be
exciting 100 is going to be not like i'm
gonna do this
here's the thing man it is freaking hard
to do jiu-jitsu against someone that is
avoiding jiu-jitsu
and
you know that can be really hard
um
and if that's the game that andre plays
then that might be boring hey if andre
goes adam right on we're gonna have an
awesome an awesome match
uh but
that could happen we could we i'm
worried that might be
not as exciting as we want it to be
and i started talking yesterday who was
i talking to i was talking to some some
people at camp and i was like
some kind of a hybrid like in wrestling
you you can get called for stalling
and
here's the problem with that
calling people for stalling in jiu jitsu
goes against one of the principles of
jujitsu which is conservation of energy
right so my goal if i'm going against a
big wrestler my actual goal
is to not work and make them work and
stall that's my goal that's how
jiu-jitsu wins in that situation
so to create a rule where you can't do
that
you can't stall which is technically
what you're doing right you're stalling
you're holding someone in your guard
you're stalling you're making them
trying to pass you're stalling you're
not attacking you're not trying to sweep
them you're not you're just that's
stalling
so there's a problem with that rule
because it goes against one of the
principles of jiu jitsu which kind of
sucks yeah and if you look at like the
match with galvo and i think it was
huron or hannah gracie where
where he where he was showing how to
defend
someone who was a world champion
remember this match metamorphosis
metamorphosis there you go who is
showing what so so basically was it
henna or huron you know hit her in
gracie and he fought galvol and hiro
doesn't compete and galvan was a world
champion at this point
and galvol was trying to submit him for
10 20 minutes yeah 20. doesn't submit it
why well he played he played defense
you know he he survived he played
defense and good to go it wasn't a draw
because it was a submission
you know what i mean so
you know i think andre knows both sides
of of that so i hope i hope he engages i
mean after the whole situation with you
know gordon slapping him and everything
man i'd want to
yeah i'd want to prove something you
know what i mean like when they had that
little exchange
uh
that's that yeah i mean i hope it helped
its fireworks you know i mean yeah and i
guess the reason i brought that up is
because you know we're here at jiu jitsu
camp so jiu-jitsu is on the mind but
also like just talking about the
popularity of jiu jitsu and
how so many more people are engaged the
biggest camp we've ever had right
biggest camp we've ever had in because
of that explosion
man adding two new looms to the factory
they showed up on friday
we're gonna get those things installed
and start ripping out more ghees
and obviously new grappling shorts which
you're gonna try yeah yeah yeah might
have to make some tweaks they're
freaking nice though that material is
perfect yeah that's a it's a weird
material because you feel like it's not
even on you like you kind of feel like
you're freaking in spartacus uh over
there grappling naked you know what i'm
saying it's so
like light in fact it's gonna hold you
back man it's freaking legit
uh did you
yes or no get tears in your eyes when i
promoted my daughter to blue belt i did
i did i i uh
i get it amanda said my wife says to me
the only time you cry is belts and
babies you don't cry when people die i
don't i don't cry at death it's belts
and babies
i know the i i i don't know what it is
about babies i i
honestly if there's a baby around crying
i sweat immediately because you know
having babies and getting up in the
middle of the night you kind of get into
this
uh difficult sleeping situation so i
i'll sweat when there's a baby crying
near me immediately
um
but belts
knowing the work it goes and the
relationship and
the commitment seeing you promote rana
was was pretty moving and i kind of was
trying to dry out my eyes a little bit
and i had one single
wipe it might have been a tear or two
but i i had a white but
your eyes were a little wet there yeah
yeah it was a little dusty in there it
was a little echo trolls
yeah yeah oh you did it was very dusty
in there yeah but but i did do it
comparatively speaking it did a good job
yeah you did you hold it here's the
here's the thing i thought about later
and it it
okay
okay so she got her blue belt
technically getting your blue belt is
not a big deal i mean honestly right
yeah standard
getting your blue bell is not a big deal
and i didn't think about this until
after
because
getting your blue belts listen it's
great you got your boob out but no one's
hyped in a big way because you got your
blue belt right
but
what what it was and the re i didn't
realize this because i'm in it
is i the journey that she's had
to get her blue belt
has been long and hard
and
really long and hard and and and it's
been long and hard
because of me as a dad
and so when she's you know when they
were little kids you heard me saying
this in the in the little speech i gave
i i had my kids training jiu jitsu
seven days a week
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday and sunday and on a couple of
three of those days no four of those
days they did striking and jiu-jitsu and
they're like ages five seven and nine
we would go to the gym on saturday at
we'd leave at 7 30 in the morning
i'd get home from the gym at two o'clock
in the afternoon they'd be with me the
whole time they'd take class they'd take
two classes of jiu jitsu in a striking
class every day of the week they're in
there they take both classes
i
made them compete
let me rephrase that i mean by the way
anyone that's listening is like hell
yeah no this is wrong it wasn't good
i made them compete when i made them
compete this is my first three kids when
i made them compete i made them compete
up a weight class up in age group up a
belt level
and
what happens when you go up a weight
weight class up in age group and up
about level you get smashed
and in my mind i'm thinking hey i'm a
great dad i'm going to make them tougher
but all it did was make jiu jitsu suck
because you go to a tournament you
compete you lose
and i just thought i'm making them
tougher and i'm not i'm actually making
jiu jitsu soccer for them making it not
making it a bad experience
and eventually
you know the they got old enough where
it was like we you know where i don't
want to do this anymore
and my two daughters you know
at a certain age and they're the they
were the oldest of the three and i have
four now but they were the oldest of
three you know like they
protested to a point where it's like you
know my wife said hey
well this is like
you can't do this to these girls anymore
so you know we
we let's say we settled it down you know
didn't train as much but
and then luckily
uh you know
rana when she got to high school
she
i persuaded her to wrestle
i persuaded her to wrestle and to be
quite honest with you i persuaded her to
wrestle with money
i i was like i will pay you to wrestle
i'll pay you to go and wrestle
and so she did it
and it took a little while before she
wasn't doing it for the money anymore
she was doing it she was into it
but again this is after like going
through
a lot of stress and tournaments as a
little kid and
you know jiu jitsu tournaments and all
that
and now she's wrestling she wrestled all
through high school um you know her
first year she's the only girl in the
wrestling team
there's a wrestling room a sweaty
gross wrestling room filled with
ringworm and filled with ringworm and
filled with you know 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 year old boys
that's what she's in there with and she
stuck it out
and she ended up you know
going through that program and
eventually making it to state
in california which is a huge deal and
and uh first person from her school
that's made it to state in like
35 years or something like this so and
it was her like the program
the program just didn't have the the the
wherewithal to to get a student to do
that she did it you know
um
and then finally she goes to college
and while she's at college
she
decides she's going to try that jiu
jitsu again
which is freaking awesome and
you know what
after about a week
she called me she's crying
she crying over her first week of jiu
jitsu
no one wants to train with me i don't
think anyone wants to train with a girl
no one wants to train with me and you
know
it's stress there's college and all this
other stuff going on there's a little
morsel of her life and there's a lot of
stuff going on and this is where it
comes out and i'm like hey don't worry
if this would be cool you know you're
going to get to know people it's fine
just just keep going please keep going
and sure she's kept going
um paragon slow
and that's where she trains and great i
ended up going up there teaching
teaching a little bit up there but just
a great academy she ended up making
great friends and
and working her ass off
and this is you know this is what she's
21 now so we're talking about like a 16
year journey right this is a long this
is most of her life you know what i'm
saying
and so then finally so when she comes
back so now she's been training for two
two years up there hard
hard two days you know stuff like this
and
so she comes back down to san diego
this summer and she's teaching she's
helping teach kids classes but she's
training all the time training and
immediately my black belts are like dude
you need to get your i rolled with her
yeah you didn't get to grow another
colored belt
and i kind of felt like well you know
she's up at up at paragon now and that's
like you know her teachers and her
instructors
and so i just said hey guys you know
she's up at paragon she'll get you know
hopefully get promoted when she gets
back up there and then like she's
tapping out a bunch of people in the
academy and my black belts once again
you know
coach adam's like dude come on
uh coach brian's like dude you're you
kidding me
then i rolled with her and i was like oh
okay this is not fair
and uh so finally what i did reached out
to her professors up there
and i sent him a text on it or a message
on instagram gave my phone number and
said hey i need to talk to you can jocko
can you give me a call
and uh the coach chris he called me up
and i knew the number from that area
code and i answered hey what hello this
is jocko and he's like hey it's chris
he goes i've been waiting for this call
and i was like that's like the best
thing i've ever heard so you know he
didn't want to promote her because it's
my daughter i didn't want to promote her
because you know she's been training
with them they're putting a lot of work
and effort into her but
so that was cool so she did one more
tournament as a white belt double gold
and then we came out here to camp and
got the promotion so so
again i realized afterwards i was like
it's kind of weird that i kind of like
echo you got your black belt yeah at
camp yeah right we all understand that's
a big deal right that's
15 years of training for you that's
getting smashed compete like all those
things everyone kind of gets that but
for randos it's like oh it's like oh she
got a blue belt that's pretty cool but i
think it was like everybody kind of
sensed it because people were freaking
hyped oh yeah man that place was crazy
of course she was crying oh yeah they
were crying you weren't crying they were
crying
that was awesome
that's what it's about and and
yeah that's what it's all about it's
what it's all about and jiu jitsu is
something that brings really brings
people together and look just like you
can't impose things on your platoon and
you can't impose things on your
workforce you can't impose things on
your family but you can
if you're lucky you can help them see
the light you can help them you can help
show them the path and when they find
that path even when you show it to them
and it's there and they decide you know
you can you you can lead a a horse to
water but you can't make a drink but
when you get them there and they jump in
man that's that's uh
one of the best things you could hope
for so
that was kind of the highlight of camp
for me dude it was awesome
[Laughter]
uh all right what else anything else
pete any closing thoughts
no man i appreciate you having me on uh
appreciate the obviously all the all the
support over the years and of course uh
you uh telling the world about what
we're doing and why and keeping
everybody's attention on it because with
all the attention grabbing going on
these days
anyone giving
anything time these days is valuable so
um
man appreciate you appreciate bringing
me on again it's awesome uh well uh
you'd be on all the time if you weren't
freaking living in farmington maine and
i wasn't living in san diego california
and and listen look
what we're doing right now
this is a campaign this is not one
battle
and this that we are going to lose we're
going to miss things and we have missed
things and we're going to make mistakes
uh but
there are opportunities out there
and
what we are going to do is we're going
to make everything in america and you
know i told this story yesterday when
the factory
it's no compromise
it's a no compromise situation
and i you i i actually i do remember the
item we were making
like what do you call the the
you we were making spats right
and we needed an elastic waistband
and you and i were
having a conversation and someone came
up with a solution it was you you said
hey uncle i'm like hey man when are we
getting these spats like what
what's happening with that and you're
like well it's pause it's going to be
the manufacturer is going to take four
months for you know before they can tool
this thing up blah blah blah okay or we
got to get this machine and we'll be
able to do ourselves okay i'm like
you know are there any solutions finally
we get a solution the solution is hey
there's a overseas company that can have
this stuff to us in three weeks
airship boom done
and
you were just like no compromise
and i was like of course no compromise
and
that
that attitude is hard it's hard to hold
the line and listen
do you compromise in life
when
your spouse wants something and you want
something else and you compromise to
come to a conclusion yeah do you
compromise when you're on a team and
you're working together and someone's
got one plan and you've got a different
idea and you compromise to make things
work yes absolutely do you compromise
when you negotiate
to make a deal happen yes you absolutely
do so in life you got to compromise but
there's things
also in life that you don't compromise
on
and where you hold the line
and that's what we're doing here
we're doing it a jocko fuel we're doing
it origin we're not going to compromise
we're going to hold the line and the
reason we're able to do that
is because everyone that's listening to
this right now so
none of this happens
not none of the zero nothing this
doesn't exist what we're talking about
doesn't exist without you that's sitting
there listening to this podcast right
now listening to what we're doing
participating in what we're doing
without your support
none of this happens
so thank you for your support
and i'm gonna tell you right now
we will not let you down
echo charles yes sir
how can uh people
support the podcast how can they support
themselves how can they support these
companies and how can they in doing so
support america
what do you got what do you got to do
well some of this is just one big
reminder you know because you guys been
kind of talking about it for a long time
but yeah so reminder or uh a recap we'll
say jacofuel.com
jockofuel.com we got
mulk the new monk rtds ready to drink if
you didn't pick not yet online it's not
yet on no not yet we haven't made enough
yet yeah we have made enough yet okay
but soon we'll be on the lookout for
that one how about that yeah because
we're over here all week drill not only
they kind of ran out quick but
we stole some from the warehouse to
drink this yeah yeah we experienced that
one that's good a little detail that i
noticed about the rtd
they're like you'd think the powder is
more versatile because you can mix stuff
in the in the thing but this becomes
more versatile in a different way
because you can use it on other things
like cereal cookies i'm not saying i did
that i'm not saying i didn't do that but
i'm just saying you'll put it on other
stuff typically you don't mix up a
protein shake add your favorite this and
that and then put it on so you don't do
that usually but this one you do that
i think we all found that out pretty
quick because i saw a lot of people
doing that stuff i like the double
hitter mulch in one hand going the other
it's a good morning double hitter you
know what i'm saying
mole can go baby oh can go that makes
complete sense to me
also a reminder or we didn't talk about
the joint warfare stuff or whatever but
yeah just look after your joints yeah
we're not getting younger
look out for you are you getting older
pay attention hey i'm over here doing
the best thing
so yes joint warfare super krill oil got
some vitamin d3
general health these these are important
things if the what if your oil runs out
in your car
all right that's okay that's not good
yeah yeah it's dean lister would say
that's a problem
i'm saying anyway so pay attention to
these things um where kidmonk does for
the kids of course it's like the kids
version um yeah all this stuff at
jocklefield.com
places yeah also you get you can get the
drinks at wawa
actually the rtd mulk is going to
it is we already shipped i believe so
if you're east coast you got that wawa
go in there and get that milk haters
yeah and it should be it should be going
in
by like it goes it gets shipped to their
whatever and then they ship it to the
store so
between mid and end of
september it'll be in and it's mulch and
go people
and maybe grab a hoagie too
uh vitamin shop h-e-b
there's i i failed to get this list on
here
we're in a bunch of retailers we'll get
that out to you i need to add that into
this so you all know so jockofield.com
you can get on amazon as well
there you go
originusa.com everything we just talked
about that's all going on at
originusa.com
boots jeans keys
rash guards spats in the hunt line the
entire haunt line
it's available uh go get some of that we
appreciate it jackostore.com
yeah what do you got going on there echo
charles hey we're all on the path you
know you want to represent disciplinary
freedom let's not forget about that no
we definitely know the rules about that
one
you want to represent that that's where
that's where you can get that stuff at
jackostore.com we got the short locker
which is the subscription
new design every month yeah i've seen a
lot of representations there's a lot of
people in maine on that subscription bro
there's a lot of people like camp on
that subscription
it's freaking legit yeah they're looking
good yeah that's like flying kind of
like flying the flag old school yes sir
like you're this is hey yeah do you call
it the subscript are you like you got to
get on that subscript subscription yes
sometimes subscription might be scary
but on the on an official level it's
called the shirt locker the shoulder
shirt like the shu rt you know
i could i got what you're putting down
man come on now
oh but yeah yeah that's a good one a lot
of good feedback on that one we've got
some new stuff coming on subscribe to
the podcast you know that
jacquelineground.com you know that
flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer i got a
bunch of books
check them out
only cry for the living by holly mckay
uh
that girl risked her life to go in and
write these books go in there and buy
that book see that store see what war is
like like almost as it's unfolding
my wife's reading it right now she's
really enjoying it it's it's really good
book yeah and joy might be the wrong
word well because it's hard to enjoy
she's really engaged with the book
it's a tough one um yeah you know i
wrote a bunch of other books check them
out echelonfront.com
we solve problems through leadership
this is what the team at echelon front
does all the time
culture merging of culture performance
leadership
in every single industry we're there so
check out echelonfront.com we have an
event the event that you talked about
pete that that jason came to it's called
the muster
uh the next one is atlanta unfortunately
it's sold out but
go on there come to one of our live live
events as well and then on top of that
look you might not be able to come to a
live event
that's why we have online training
extremeownership.com we got a bunch of
people from origin on there too oh yeah
yeah oh yeah a bunch of people from
origin are on there which is awesome to
see
and we we have live sessions we do we
have pre-recorded training sessions it's
just it's just a way to train leadership
like and this is the interesting thing
years ago if someone would have said hey
people are gonna learn jujitsu by
online academies what would you have
thought hell no hell no what do you
think now oh hell yeah i mean
yeah hell yes so it's the same thing
with leadership
and by the way just like jiu-jitsu or
playing guitar or playing basketball
you're not born with the skills you need
to learn them same thing with leadership
we made an online training academy
extremeownership.com go check that i'll
help you with leadership and it doesn't
mean you're in charge of 420 people at
your
at your company if you're alive and you
interact with other human beings you're
in a leadership position
and you're leading them
so go and check that out
uh if you want to help out
some service members
active and retired you want to help with
their families gold star families check
out mark lee's mom she's got an
unbelievable charity organization
what they do is they help vets with
their health and give them
solutions to their health that the va
doesn't cover
so it's just an outstanding organization
she's an unbelievable woman america's
mightywarriors.org
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved also check out micah fink he's
up there taking vets into the wilderness
on horses for 41 days
where they can find themselves
heroes and horses.org
incredible organization
the social media thing
it's a double-edged sword we get it
there's an algorithm that's trying to
grab you it's trying to waste your time
there's also some positive that can come
out of it
if you want to follow uh
on the social media
jocko fuel is at jackal fuel go check
that one out go check out jocklefield so
you know what's happening you know where
you can buy stuff you know when new
stuff comes out at jocko fuel
check that one out at origin usa on
instagram
that's where origin's at pete's actually
at pete dot origin still haven't gotten
that blue check we talked about it last
year
yeah they don't know no love for the
man for the yankee
the blue oh like the confirmed
are you guys so many fake accounts now
man i get emails every day from people
and they're soliciting them for
crypto stuff
new accounts all the time make any big
uh investments there in the crypto world
through some random dude on instagram
that sounds like a good plan uh yeah so
check that out check out pete check out
origin check out jaco fuel if you want
to check out echo and me echo's adequate
charles i am at jocko willink and
pete thanks once again thank you
thanks for uh all you've done and all
you're doing you know you went out there
with your friends and family and cut
down a bunch of trees in the middle of
the woods to make a factory and that
took some serious guts to do and you did
it and we appreciate that and
on top of that thanks to all the
hard-working people at origin usa and
jocko fuel who are out there cutting and
sewing and designing and creating and
packing and shipping and cleaning and
working
thanks to all of you for everything you
that you do you all are the backbone of
these companies and we thank you for
your hard work and your commitment to
this dream and you know what to all the
hard working men and women of this great
nation and you're out there
i see you all the time
in the fields and in the factories
on the construction sites and in the
cubicles on the oil rigs and the utility
poles in hospitals and hotels
in restaurants and warehouses
to all of you that toil and labor every
day thank you for what you do
what it's what allows the lights to come
on
and we appreciate it and thanks to all
the military out there for for
protecting the freedom that we have that
allows us to do what we're doing and we
will do our port our part to build the
economy and support you
and also thanks to
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
and all first responders thank you for
protecting our safety and security here
at home and everyone else out there
thank you
for your support
thank you for listening and thank you
for believing and thank you for
understanding what is at risk and thank
you for seeing what is happening in the
world and seeing the darkness in the
world
but still moving toward the light
freedom is not free it takes sacrifice
it takes guts and it takes grit and it
takes work
so let's go get after it
and get to work
and until next time this is pete and
echo and jocko
out